le mandat du nouveau président directeur
général qui sera désigné par le bureau
sur proposition du président du sénat
prendra effet le 1er juin 2021 pour une
durée de trois ans cet appel à
candidatures s'est clos le 18 février
dernier
notre commission de sélection après
avoir délibéré le 9 mars sur la base des
dossiers reçus a décidé d'entendre trois
candidats dans l'ordre alphabétique il
s'agit de messieurs christopher baldelli
de monsieur damien fleurot et de
monsieur emmanuel kessler et cie présent
ces trois candidats vont donc être
auditionné cet après midi à l'issue de
ces auditions notre commission de
sélection après en avoir délibéré
transmettra au président du sénat le ou
les noms du ou des candidats retenus
leur audition interviendra le jeudi 15
avril prochain alors issue la
désignation du nouveau pdg de public
sénat pour les trois prochaines années
fera l'objet d'un vote par les membres
du bureau pour aujourd'hui et dans un
premier temps nous allons procéder à un
tirage au sort afin de déterminer
l'ordre de passage et trois candidats
auditionnés et ce tirage au sort vient
monsieur loïc harvey en sa qualité de
plus jeune membre de notre commission et
j'invite donc un huissier à lui tendre
l'urne afin qu'ils puissent exécuter ces
voix-là la présidente monsieur emmanuel
kessler
puis monsieur damien fleurot et enfin
monsieur christopher baldelli
merci beaucoup chers collègues je vous
rappelle que ces auditions comme le
tirage au sort auquel nous venons de
procéder sont retransmises en direct sur
le site internet du sénat et par public
sénat en différé d'une heure pour des
raisons de partage de l'antenne avec lcp
assemblée nationale
chaque audition durera quarante minutes
d composé comme suit d'abord dix minutes
de présentation de sa candidature par le
candidat puis 25 minutes des changes
avec la commission il aura six questions
réponses pour que chaque candidat
ce qui veut dire trois minutes par
question réponse et enfin cinq minutes
de conclusion par le candidat
donc je pris donc monsieur emmanuel
kessler de bien vouloir prendre place et
messieurs fleurot et baldelli de bien
vouloir quitter la salle je vous
remercie
ils vont être conduits dans une pièce
isolée avant d'être appelé chacun pour
leurs auditions respectives et ils
resteront d'ici là son téléphone mobile
ni tablettes ni télévision afin qu'ils
ne puissent pas regardé la prestation de
leurs concurrents de sorte que la plus
stricte égalité dont les conditions
d'audition soit respectée alors monsieur
kessler
je vous rappelle les règles que je viens
d'énoncer votre audition
monsieur kessler a duré 40 minutes
d'abord dix minutes de présentation de
votre candidature
puis 25 minutes des changes avec la
commission enfin cinq minutes pour votre
conclusion
je vous donne donc la parole monsieur
qu'est cela pour une durée de 10 minutes
bien madame la présidente monsieur le
questeur mais l'âme les sénatrices
messieurs les sénateurs
je suis très heureux d'être devant vous
pour vous présenter ma candidature à la
présidence de public sénat et vous
exposer mon projet pour les trois
prochaines années
nous vivons un moment sans précédent de
crises sanitaires économiques sociales
culturelles de crise de l'information et
de fragilité démocratique
j'ai réfléchi et si j'ai décidé de
solliciter à nouveau votre confiance
c'est parce que je suis habité par une
conviction et elle est la raison de mon
engagement c'est que la mission de notre
chaîne parlementaire retisser le lien
entre la politique et les français
cette mission n'a jamais été aussi
crucial aussi nécessaire aussi actuel or
cette période si difficile avec notre
identité
elle est aussi riche de formidables
opportunités pour expliquer au plus
grand public
votre action celle de tous les sénateurs
avec pluralisme et impartialité en
prenant le temps de la pédagogie pour
répondre à l'aspiration de plus en plus
forte des français à la proximité et
pour nourrir avec vous le débat d'idées
constructif sur nos enjeux d'avenir du
fonds n'est pas du clas alors cette
vision je peux en témoigner elle est
partagée par l'ensemble de l'équipe que
j'ai la chance de diriger leur
implication jeu les mesures et plus
encore dans cette année de pandémie la
capacité de toutes et tous
non seulement de s'adapter mais surtout
d'innover
alors oui nous avons des appuis solides
l'élan est là et je veux maintenant
mettre toute mon énergie pour faire plus
que jamais de public sénat
le média parlementaires de tous les
publics
public sénat tout public ce projet cap
il a trois grandes ambitions un élargir
la visibilité de votre action et du rôle
du sénat deux approfondir le lien que
nous avons avec les territoires 3
déployeurs aussi une nouvelle approche
numérique multiplateforme et à la
demande
et tout cela dans un cadre de gestion
maîtrisée que j'évoquerai ensuite c'est
donc d'abord et c'est mon premier point
une nouvelle ambition pour le
rayonnement du sénat et l'action des
sénateurs je vous propose de déployer
pleinement ce que j'appelle le multiplex
parlementaire de quoi s'agit-il de la
possibilité de diffuser plusieurs
contenus liés à l'agenda du sénat
avec un format adapté à chaque
plateforme par exemple pendant que le
débat sur l'opération barkan et
retransmis sur la tnt bien aux
journalistes s'adresse sur nos abonnés
facebook comment une audition par
exemple sur les questions de laïcité et
dialogue avec les internautes
nous toucherons ainsi de plus en plus
des publics multiples avec des sujets et
des formats spécifiques c'est public
sénat est à vous et puis je veux ajouter
plus d'interaction avec les citoyens à
la rentrée sur l'écran télé nous
afficherons des qr codes à scanner qui
renverront à des contenus
complémentaires sur notre site et à la
possibilité de poser des questions ou de
commenter le mercredi c'est la journée
événement des questions au gouvernement
et bien j'introduirai des questions
citoyennes recueillies en vidéo sur les
réseaux sociaux qui vous seront
adressées lors du débrief après la
séance
un autre aspect de votre rayonnement
au-delà de votre activité ici au palais
du luxembourg
c'est votre lien avec vos territoires et
pour mieux le faire vivre
je propose à la rentrée un nouveau grand
rendez vous installé dans notre
carrefour de 22 heures l'émission
s'appellera réinventons la france
elle sera réalisée en région dans un
lieu emblématique avec en fil rouge l'un
d'entre vous une sénatrice un sénateur
entouré d'acteurs locaux de mai
r d'entrepreneurs de citoyens vous
diallo gréer réagir et avec eux à des
reportages de la rédaction
illustrant dans tous les domaines les
innovations qui vont redynamiser notre
pays construire le monde d'après par
l'initiative de terrain et qui seront
des sources d'inspiration je veux faire
de public sénat
le média de la relance par les
territoires et cela m'amène à mon autre
ambition c'est mon deuxième point faire
vivre cette énergie des territoires
notre force votre force c'est cet
ancrage territorial et le refus du du
parisianisme
cet ancrage doit irriguer l'ensemble de
nos programmes et inclure tous les
territoires de métropole et des outre
mer voilà le pacte territoire que je
vous propose le sénat c'est la maison
des collectivités locales et bien public
sénat sera la maison des médias locaux
je propose une alliance stratégique
globale avec la presse quotidienne
régionale et les télévisions locales
indépendantes dont celle des outre-mer
et j'engagerai cette démarche dès ce
printemps
concrètement l'accord inclure en
particulier un club de la presse des
régions dans la perspective des
prochaines échéances électorales
notre participation et notre relais à
des événements de presse quotidienne
régionale dans les territoires notre
association aussi à des actions de la
pqr en faveur de l'éducation aux médias
je m'engagerai avec territoire tv
nouveau réseau des télévisions locales
de la pqr pour coproduire à la rentrée
sur notre plateau leur nouveau rendez
vous commun d'actualité vitrine des
chaînes qui sera diffusée en
complémentarité sur public sénat
troisième direction public sénat tout
public c'est un média multi plateformes
et à la demande
cela repose sur la distribution et le
déploiement de nos contenus au delà de
la télévision sur tous les écrans
alors nous avons déjà le replay la télé
de rattrapage mais on doit répondre
encore davantage aux nouvelles habitudes
de consommation numérique à la fois sur
le web via les
box des opérateurs les réseaux sociaux
les nouvelles plateformes
c'est aussi un moyen de toucher un
public plus large et plus jeune
sur la plateforme twitch nous avons été
les premiers à vous faire dialoguer avec
les jeunes
et ça marche et bien ce temps d'avancé
on va le garder avec d'autres formats
innovants sur d'autres réseaux sociaux
tout cela va prendre force dans une
nouvelle offre public sénat à la demande
publicsenat.fr va devenir une
plate-forme ou avec des vignettes claire
et attractive
chacune et chacun trouve gratuitement
bien sûr et à tout maman tous les
contenus qui les intéressent où je veux
quand je veux sur tout écran voilà le
nouveau public sénat concrètement je
vais mettre en ligne en janvier 2022
un site internet entièrement rénové à
côté des articles d'actualité il sera
aux meilleurs standards du moment pour
la mise à disposition de la diversité de
nos productions des auditions
parlementaires les documentaires bien
sûr mais aussi des formats exclusif pour
le web et sur le mobile en janvier 2023
ce sera le lancement de l'appli public
sénat elle portera au plus l'eau au plus
haut ce qu'on peut appeler l'expérience
public saidal alors vous allez me
demander pourrons-nous concilier cet
élan nouveau ce projet ambitieux avec la
rigueur budgétaire
et bien la réponse est oui et je veux en
prendre l'engagement
j'en viens donc à la gestion de
l'entreprise je m'inscris pleinement
dans la perspective d'une poursuite du
gel en valeur absolue de notre dotation
et d'une stricte limitation pour
l'évolution de notre masse salariale
jusqu'en 2024
c'est par des économies de gestion et
donc en dégageant des marges
d'autofinancement que nous allons
assurer notre développement territorial
et numérique et avec aussi un nouvel
effort sur le parrainage de la rigueur
de gestion elle repose également sur une
relation solide et constructive avec lcp
assemblée nationale
la limite c'est notre autonomie et notre
indépendance qu'il faut absolument
préserver à vos côtés je ne mettrai
jamais le doigt dans un engrenage qui à
vous dire est à une forme de confusion
voir un esprit de fusion qui serait
contraire aux bicamérisme et diluerait
la marque forte public sénat qui porte
le sénat en elle mais dans le même temps
je souhaite une coopération volontariste
en optimisant la gestion de notre canal
commun et de notre diffusion en
renforçant aussi nos synergies
éditoriales
je propose par exemple une nouvelle
émission commune à dialogue entre
députés et sénateurs pour montrer ce
bicamérisme en action
je termine avant notre et chance nous
avons affirmé ces dernières années notre
singularité
on est différent des autres puis nous
avons démontré notre modernité une
nouvelle image un nouveau ton devant
nous
ce que je veux aujourd'hui pour public
c'est là c'est renforcer notre puissance
2021 2024 si vous m'accordez votre
confiance
ce sera pour public sénat le temps du
rayonnement le socle d'audience et la
plus de 29 millions de téléspectateurs
sont venus sur notre canal en avril 2020
c'est un record la fréquentation de
notre site publicsenat.fr a doublé en un
an et nous allons encore progresser
l'audience est un indicateur de succès
mais jamais contrairement à d'autres
médias
le critère de décision éditoriale ce qui
prime c'est notre rayonnement dans le
paysage audiovisuel numérique et
politique
voilà l'objectif alors l'état d'esprit
que je veux insuffler aux équipes c'est
que tout est possible et si je suis là
aujourd'hui devant vous c'est pour
relever le challenge de ces défis
nouveaux et essentielle en ces temps
d'incertitude entretenir avec nos
concitoyens plus encore renouer avec
notre jeunesse
une conversation républicaine je ne vois
pas de mission plus exaltante à ce
moment de notre histoire
à ce moment de mon parcours de missions
plus proche de vos valeurs et de celle
du sénat
merci monsieur gaessler nous allons
maintenant passer au temps des échanges
avec la commission et nous allons donc
procéder à toute une série de questions
auxquelles vous allez répondre et je
vais me permettre de poser la première
de ses six questions
alors messieurs kessler selon vous quels
sont les principaux enjeux et défis de
public sénat dans le paysage audiovisuel
actuelle comment définiriez-vous ses
missions intrinsèque
qu'est ce qui la différencie des autres
chaînes monsieur kessler en particulier
les chaînes d'information vous avez
parlé d'elle cpn et des coopérations et
qu'est ce qui la différencie aussi et
est ce que vous pouvez vous préciser cet
aspect des choses
résidente cette différenciation elle est
en effet très importante aujourd'hui
elle est de plus en plus et elle passe
par plusieurs caractéristiques
la première je crois c'est le temps long
ce que nous avons dans l'univers
numérique à travers le fracas et la
succession des tweets et sur les chaînes
d'information ou un événement chasse
l'autre j'allais dire à toute vitesse
sans toujours d'ailleurs que la
hiérarchie soit compréhensible c'est une
une succession d'un faux dont les
téléspectateurs ont besoin à titre d'
alerte mais qui ne suffit pas a
comprendre a expliqué à donner du sens
et donc la caractéristique de public
sénat
si ce temps long cette prise de distance
cette capacité de réflexion que nous
avons dans nos débats des débats qui
peuvent être contradictoires mais qui
sont constructifs ou d'ailleurs à
l'image de ce qu'est votre assemblée on
peut confronter des opinions divergentes
mais où il y a toujours du respect et
moins je crois c'est pour ça que j'ai
parlé de conversations républicaine que
cette tonalité là elle est extrêmement
marquantes
le deuxième point qui nous différencie
des chaînes d'information c'est la
capacité
je dirais d'avoir une information plus
riche et plus variée qui s'appuie
d'ailleurs sur votre activité
car bien souvent sur les chaînes
d'information vous avez pendant une
journée le mans
titres développés à l'infini or chez
nous où je vais vous prendre un exemple
la discussion sur la proposition
sécurité globale et bien la plupart des
chaînes d'information se sont concentrés
uniquement sur cet article 24 et nous
mêmes nous avons mis en avant votre
débat sur les polices municipales qui
est un débat qui est extrêmement
concernant pour les citoyens et sur
lequel les médias qu'ils allaient dire
cherche d'abord les faits politiques au
sens pardon il ne fait pas une critique
de politique peut-être plus
politiciennes ne mettre moins l'accent
c'est ça notre devoir c'est ça notre
mission en s'appuyant encore une fois
sur l'ensemble de vos travaux je vous en
ce moment la richesse des missions
d'information qui font suite à la
situation de pandémie dans laquelle nous
sommes sur les jeunes sur la pauvreté
eh bien je crois que nous avons une
matière formidable à mettre en avant
extrêmement concernante demain je sais
que vous aurez un débat je crois sur la
pratique sportive
voilà une question de vie quotidienne
elle sera moins traités sur les chaînes
généralistes
elle sera chez nous je termine sur lcp
assemblée nationale
nous avons des complémentarités je les
dis il faut travailler ensemble mais ce
qui me paraît important c'est aussi
notre spécificité et c'est notamment
cette dimension territoriale qui non
seulement est là parce que nous sommes
l'émanation du sénat et c'est déjà
considérable
mais là aussi parce que cela correspond
aujourd'hui et ils le disent à toutes
les attentes des français et nos
associations nos partenariats avec les
associations d'élus
notre présence dans les grands congrès
de l'association des maires de france ou
des régions c'est une marque forte de
public sénat notre présence sur le
terrain des plusieurs départements
visités chaque semaine c'est une marque
forte qu'il va falloir continuer à
développer d'ailleurs je propose de
nouveaux axes dans ce partenariat par
exemple avec les associations d'élus
kessler la parole et à monsieur joël
guerriau merci madame la présidente
monsieur kessler dans votre propos
introductif vous avez montré votre
volonté de diversifier le
le public est à l'audience de lâcher et
d'augmenter la violence de la chaîne par
de nouveaux outils
vous avez présenté votre projet
multiplex parlementaire on voit bien que
vous avez l'intention de faire évoluer
les modalités de diffusion de public
sénat sur la tnt
j'aimerais savoir quels sont les à quel
horizon où vous voulez faire d'autre
d'autres projets avec quel mode art and
alternative de diffusion souhaitez vous
privilégié dans ce cadre là vous avez
bien sûr plusieurs vecteurs que vous
avez cités vous avez cité facebook vous
avez cité les réseaux sociaux que vous
avez déjà plus ou moins prêter puisque
vous parliez tout à l'heure en
introduction de l'opération barkan avec
facebook
alors quelles sont les initiatives que
vous souhaitez privilégier maintenant et
où pensez-vous coûts gagner encore
davantage d'audience ce qui me paraît
d'abord très important il ya un
préalable c'est que notre diffusion sur
la tnt demeure incontournable et
indispensable parce que d'abord elle
nous a fait arriver en 2005
j'allais dire dans la ligue 1 de
l'audiovisuel enfin dans le club fermé
des chaînes qui compte
et aujourd'hui on se bat pour être sur
la tnt et d'ailleurs vous avez vu que le
csa ne va pas changer les numéros c'est
notre chance parce que le numéro 13 il
nous a porté chance
pourquoi la tnt demeure indispensable
même si elle à monsieur le testeur nous
en parlons parfois un coût élevé c'est
parce que 20% des foyers français ne
reçoivent la télévision que par la tnt
que c'est un mode gratuit sans collecte
de données et universel qui couvre la
totalité de nos territoires et donc ici
plus qu'ailleurs je pense qu'on est
attaché par rapport à notre mission de
service public à la tnt
alors après il faut en maîtriser les
coûts nous avons négocié d'ailleurs avec
nos amis d'el cpam pour faire en sorte
que le prestataire de diffusion
principal tdf n'augmentent pas trop si
coup mais je dirais qu'à moyen terme
d'ailleurs le csa est plutôt sur une
optique de modernisation de la tnt la
tnt c'est vraiment un enjeu de
démocratie audiovisuelle
dans le même temps bien entendu de plus
en plus de français et notamment les
jeunes qui ne regardent plus la
télévision reçoivent des signaux par
d'autres canaux ya les box des
opérateurs
il y a ce qu'on appelle le tt je veux
pas être technique mais ce sont toutes
ces plateformes qui permettent de
recevoir le signal télévisé sur son
ordinateur sur son mobile et nous devons
avoir c'est un peu ce que j'expliquais
une stratégie de présence la plus large
possible à la fois sûre ça veut dire le
flux de notre chaîne et sur ses
émissions cette consommation
pardon d'employés là encore un terme un
peu techniques de plus en plus
délinéarisée c'est-à-dire émissions par
émissions contenues par contenu
indépendamment de la programmation le à
la télévision on donne rendez vous aux
téléspectateurs mais il faut lui offrir
sur l'ensemble des plateformes
l'ensemble des outils et avec les
formats adaptés parce qu'on ne s'adresse
pas de la même façon à un public sur
facebook ou sur molotov où on peut aussi
mettre des vignettes sur nos émissions
eh bien il faut offrir toute cette gamme
de possibilités pour les contenus public
sénat donc raisonner en termes de
contenu et plus seulement c'est
l'évolution d'aujourd'hui en termes de
télévision la parole est à messieurs
vincent capo-canellas merci madame la
présidente monsieur kessler le contenu
le contexte pardon budgétaire contraint
vous l'avez vous même rappeler comment
comptez vous continuer à mettre mieux
encore à la à l'antenne en valeur tous
les territoires y compris les outre-mer
en tenant bien sûr compte et en me
rendant compte de l'activité des
sénatrices et des sénateurs sur le
terrain dans l'existant dans l'exercice
de leur mandat
par ailleurs comment bien assurer
l'égalité femmes hommes à l'antenne
alors commence peut-être par la dernière
partie votre question qui suis
évidemment très atypique très attaché la
parité peut être un objectif
elle est dans le fonctionnement de
l'entreprise c'est important un comité
direction entièrement paritaire un
indice même d'égalité femmes hommes qui
est plus favorable aux femmes dans notre
entreprise c'est un élément positif
et puis vous me parlez de la parité à
l'antenne d'abord nous n'avons plus de
présentatrice que deux présentateurs
mais la grosse difficulté ce sont les
plateaux avec les expertes en parité
avec les experts
reconnaissez avec moi qu'il y a encore
une majorité d'hommes part
les sénateurs l'ensemble de votre
collègue même si la féminisation a
beaucoup progressé
donc ça c'est un alimente maîtrisons pas
mais nous nous entourons c'est très
difficile d'arriver à la parité je peux
vous dire que mes équipes disent même
que depuis la pandémie c'est devenu
encore plus difficile peut-être parce
qu'il ya encore des contraintes qui
pèsent plus sur les femmes que sur les
hommes mais nous travaillons par exemple
avec un think tank agir pour l'égalité
pour essayer au maximum de recourir à
des expertes ou à des intervenants de
nos plateaux qui souhaitent aussi des
femmes dans le mouvement associatif dans
le monde économique et donc c'est un
effort de tous les instants en la
matière je suis pour des indicateurs de
progression
je vous le dis à titre personnel je suis
contre les quotas ce que je pense que
les quotas fige les choses je pense que
ce qui est important c'est de mesurer
notre profession d'année en année et
nous pourrons l'indiqué dans notre
prochain contrat d'objectifs et de
moyens pour ce qui concerne la
contrainte budgétaire
je veux en faire une opportunité je
considère que avoir un budget gelé tel
que le nôtre nous oblige
et ça représente un effort chaque année
a beaucoup d'imagination a beaucoup
d'agilité et nous allons continuer à
développer notre présence territoriale
et numérique grâce à des économies de
gestion
nous en avons fait vous l'avez suivi
monsieur le questeur avec nous avec
l'internet et l'internalisation de
l'exploitation des personnels qui
exploitent notre régie de production
c'est une marche d'économie assez
importante moi je souhaite poursuivre
sur cette tendance en examinant
l'ensemble de nos contrats de
prestations pour voir comment on peut
pas tout internaliser mais sur certaines
prestations nous pouvons internaliser
davantage autrement dit ce qui a été
initié je souhaite le poursuivre nous
allons par exemple renégocier
prochainement notre contrat de diffusion
de notre signal une fois produit ce
qu'on appelle là réside diffusion ya
probablement des choses que nous pouvons
faire pour dégager des économies donc
autofinancement par des économies et
fort également sur le parrainage
si pour la quatrième question monsieur
loïc r
monsieur kessler trois mandats la suite
ne serait ce pas trop long comment se
remettre en cause quand on a déjà mis en
place une nouvelle organisation et
nouvelle grille par exemple comment
mieux faire connaître l'institution
sénatoriales il responsabilité que nous
exercions comment également développer
de nouveaux partenariats avec les
réseaux sociaux avec la pqr mais de
manière plus précise que ce que vous
savez pu nous dire en propos liminaire
comment améliorer la gestion bref
qu'elle serait quels sont vos marges de
progression merci ce qui m'intéresse
c'est l'avenir et donc je considère
qu'il faut toujours progresser aller de
l'avant nous avons un socle mais j'ai
essayé d'expliquer que nous avions un
projet ambitieux pour ce temps du
rayonnement de public sénat
alors ce mandat si vous m'accordez votre
confiance je ne vois pas comme un
troisième mandat mais comme le premier
mandat de l'après crise je sais que vous
ne pourrez pas vous ne ferez pas votre
choix sur un bilan je vous propose de
faire votre choix sur un élan c'est cet
élan que je veux incarner parce que je
crois profondément à l'utilité à la
valeur de ce que nous représentons
public sénat et de la visibilité de
votre action que je veux accentuée en
suivant par exemple on a beaucoup
progressé sur la présence des auditions
grâce avoue d'ailleurs qu'il est captée
davantage
je pense qu'on peut faire encore un
petit peu plus ce n'est pas dit tout à
l'heure sur la notion de prospective
dans ce monde de demain vous avez
beaucoup avec la délégation à la
prospective avec en commun avec
l'assemblée l'opex le fils sur les choix
scientifiques et technologiques avec la
délégation aux droits des femmes
énormément de travaux qui dessine ses
perspectives je voudrais créer un
rendez-vous qui s'appellera les lundis
de la prospective où on mettra en avant
tout cette réflexion que vous avez sur
ce monde nouveau que nous allons bâtir
après cette frise du duke duke au vide
je voudrais ajouter concernant la durée
du mandat un élément c'est que le mandat
des présidents des chaînes
parlementaires et le plus court de tout
l'audiovisuel public dans les autres
sociétés de l'audiovisuel il est de 5
ans et donc au fond trois mandats si ce
devait être le cas à la présidence de
public sénat c'est moins que deux
mandats à la présidence de france
télévisions et puis dans vos
collectivités
quand un maire a bâti vous l'avez été
pour certains d'entre vous a commencé à
bâtir au bout de six ans il n'a pas fini
voilà on a commencé à tracer un chemin
il faut aller beaucoup plus loin être
encore beaucoup plus plus ambitieux
surtout dans une période où tout est où
tout et refonder et puis je crois aussi
que dans une période comme celle que
nous connaissons il faut à la fois
l'élan la créativité et j'ai essayé de
vous le montrer par tous les aspects que
je souhaite développer pour la période à
venir
et puis une certaine forme de stabilité
qui nous ancre et qui ancre sur tous les
collaborateurs dans une forme de
confiance dans l'avenir voilà ce que ce
que je veux vous proposer pour les trois
prochaines années pour public sénat
merci madame benbassa
bonjour monsieur kessler comme en public
sénat pourrait-elle former les jeunes à
la vie publique et aux valeurs
républicaines
ne pourrait-on pas organiser des débats
avec de jeunes élus locaux et des
sénatrices et sénateurs ou encore créer
une émission tournée vers les jeunes
incarné par un animateur de la jeune
génération
si oui comment imaginer auriez-vous ce
type d'émission plus généralement et
quelles seraient vos propositions pour
conquérir de nouveaux publics
merci oui madame la sénatrice il faut en
effet aller vers les jeunes en sachant
que c'est difficile parce qu'il se
définit la politique parce qu'ils ne
regardent plus la télévision
donc il faut pas chercher forcément à
faire des émissions de télévision au
sens classique du terme ils ne la
regarde plus c'est pour ça mais je n'y
reviens pas que nous sommes allés sur
twitch mais il faut poursuivre dans
cette direction
je propose deux choses d'abord je pense
que le dialogue entre les politiques et
notamment ceux qui sont en contact des
réalités de terrain et les jeunes ça
fonctionne donc je propose de mettre en
place une émission qui va s'appeler
dialogue jeunes citoyens on va
travailler avec des rectorats des
collèges et des lycées pour que deux
fois par an six sénateurs viennent
dialoguer autour de deux questions et
d'enjeux que nous aurons préparer avec
eux avec neuf jeunes 6 de 9 2 collèges
et puis ensuite de lisser on fera
quelques émissions par an à titre de
test
le deuxième point c'est joe crocs pour
s'adresser aux jeunes et pour les ré
ancré dans la république
plus que des propositions éditoriales et
on va faire des choses sur les réseaux
sociaux il faut leur proposer des
projets
rappelez-vous ce formidable film
d'ariane ascaride où elle arrive à
sensibiliser une classe rétive un
concours sur
l'histoire de la déportation alors ce
que nous pouvons faire et je vais le
proposer aux associations d'élus vous me
parliez de partenariat tout à l'heure je
veux bien sûr développer encore ses
partenariats
c'est un concours auprès des jeunes vis
ta ville
vis ton village vita banlieue où nous
allons leur demander de filmer leur
territoire dans un format réseau social
type youtube et nous allons préparer
bien sûr avec des associations d'élus
partenaires une sorte de cahier des
charges pour essayer de les impliquer
dans un projet et puis il y aura des
prix on peut même le doter ce prix pour
véritablement inciter et crée aussi de
l'an viii et peut-être lé envie de
continuer et je pense que c'est aussi un
élément de de lien social et de cohésion
républicaine que l'on peut créer donc
d'une part des offres éditoriales et
numérique en n'étant pas trop classique
sur le plan de la télévision et d'autre
part des projets qui vont impliquer les
jeunes et sensibiliser à ce qu'est le
sénat et public sénat comme vecteur de
deux d'intégration républicaine aussi
oui merci
la parole est à madame fille votre
projet stratégique pas plus que votre
présentation liminaire ne fait de
propositions concernant la mesure de
satisfaction du public qui constitue
pourtant une préoccupation importante
pour une chaîne de service public
pourquoi cet angle mort avez vous des
propositions dans ce domaine
merci
merci madame la sénatrice bien entendu
et jour je trouve que effectivement
c'est sous cet angle là qu'il faut poser
la question
plus que sur celui de la mesure
d'audience j'ai dit tout à l'heure ce
qui compte c'est notre influence notre
présence bien sûr nous avons quelques
indicateurs d'audience qui nous
permettent de mesurer la force de nos
programmes par exemple les questions
d'actualité par exemple nos
documentaires mais ce qui est très
important c'est de mesurer la
satisfaction de nos publics donc ça
n'est pas du tout un angle ce n'est pas
du tout part dans un angle mort de mon
projet parce que je me situe
pour que ce soit fiable dans une
tendance qui existe déjà depuis 2014
tous les trois ans nous effectuerons
pardon depuis 2011 tous les trois ans
depuis qu'il y ait un contrat
d'objectifs et de moyens d'ailleurs à
une étude qualitative avec la même
méthodologie le même institut pour
mesurer la satisfaction de nos publics
et nous en avons fait une raison
récemment qu'ils montrent
qu'effectivement la modernisation notre
chaîne et surtout je dirais la confiance
du public dans ce moment je disais au
début de crise de l'information est très
fort dans le contenu public sénat quand
on regarde public c'est là on croit ce
qu'on est en train de voir ou de lire
sur notre site internet ça c'est très
important il faut le mesurer
et puis le deuxième point qui est
intéressant c'est que ça permet de
mesurer aussi la façon de savoir si nous
remplissons notre mission de recréer du
lien entre le politique et le citoyen
entre le sénat et les citoyens de faire
connaître le sénat et nos publics nous
disent oui mais je souhaite que nous
progressions encore et nous pouvons ça
sera discutée peut-être dans le cadre du
prochain contrat d un objet d'objectifs
et de moyens rendre cet indicateur plus
fréquents l'élément qui me paraît
important c'est que dans cet indicateur
de satisfaction nous mettions puisque
j'ai parlé du public sénat à la demande
et d'une nouvelle étape de notre
développement numérique
nous nous mettions bien au centre du
questionnement la question de savoir si
désormais nos publics et ça va être le
défi des années à venir nous perçoivent
surtout pas seulement comme une chaîne
de télévision mais bien comme ce média
global dans lequel ils peuvent entrer
par différentes portes le site internet
par l'actualité et toutes les
plateformes où ils peuvent disposer des
contenus depuis mixer n'a des
documentaires aux séances d'auditions en
passant par nos magazines donc oui bien
entendu tous les trois ans actuellement
mais nous pouvons le faire plus
fréquemment une mesure de la
satisfaction c'est la bonne approche
pour mesurer cette puissance de public
sénat
merci monsieur caisse claire alors comme
vous pouvez le constater monsieur
kessler il vous reste un peu plus de dix
minutes si vous voulez approfondir
certains aspects à l'occasion de votre
conclusion
puisque le temps qui vous est imparti
est de 40 minutes au total
bien je pensais pas qu'on avait été si
rapide
voilà alors écoutez je vais je vais
conclure en vous disant ma passion pour
cette mission voilà parce que public
sénat c'est une entreprise à taille
humaine qui est agile qui en mouvement
créative et où surtout chacun a le
sentiment et c'est tellement précieux
aujourd'hui que ce qu'il fait a du sens
et c'est comme cela
à cette échelle avec ses valeurs avec ce
mode de management fondé sur l' écoute
la collaboration que notre média doit
être appréhendée par celui qui le dirige
pas comme n'importe quel média public
sénat c'est au fond une combinaison une
alchimie qu'il faut non seulement
maîtriser
j'ai l'expérience mais avec laquelle il
faut entretenir un lien affectif et moi
cette chaîne ce média multiples je les
ai vus grandir
je le connais je le vis média ouvert à
tous les publics
et je crois que nous l'avons beaucoup
évoqué mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs dans dans les minutes qui ont
précédé
il doit l'être aussi dans sa vie interne
en favorisant le parcours et la
progression professionnelle de chacune
et chacun dans la parité et la diversité
humaine sociale territoriale et en
permettant l'accès à nos métiers à des
jeunes de tous nos territoires qui n'ont
pas forcément les réseaux pourraient
entrer c'est aussi notre responsabilité
et notre mission et notre mission
j'ai des propositions pour cet
engagement dans mon projet notamment au
travers de conventions nous pourrions
passer avec des rectorats dans des zones
prioritaires des zones urbaines mais
aussi des zones rurales et aussi
d'ailleurs des outre-mer si la distance
permet de les faire un moment donné
découvrir par des stages ou pour ceux
qui cherchent un emploi par des
formations professionnelles nos nos
métiers voilà donc ça ça me paraît
extrêmement important je suis un
dirigeant bien sûr exigeant pour lui
même et pour les autres un entraîneur
qui pousse chacun et chacune à toujours
aller de l'avant et qui fait aussi
preuve d'écoutés de bienveillance de
proximité parce qu'une équipe il faut
lui montrer l'objectif mais aussi être
sur le terrain avec elle l'accompagné et
puis dans public sénat il ya le sénat le
sénat votre sénat j'ai envie de dire
notre ces dames à public sénat j'y tiens
rien ne se fait sans un dialogue
constant qui nous nourrit avec chacune
et chacun d'entre vous et le sénat c'est
mon port d'attache parce que j'ai
toujours considéré cela dès mes débuts
dans le journalisme à la gazette des
communes qu'il incarne avec vous toutes
et tous à la fois
l'ancrage dans nos territoires sans
lequel on manque toute compréhension de
la politique et l'attachement au delà
même des sensibilités partisanes et si
ce à quoi je crois aux grands principes
républicains qui doivent nous réunir sur
un plan plus personnel je suis aussi
passionné par l'idée de transmission et
c'est le rôle de notre média que de
transmettre une information fiable qui
soit utile à la formation du citoyen et
qui conforte notre démocratie
et je vous le dis ici si votre décision
me le permet je lancerai à la rentrée
sur nos antennes un grand magazine de
débat et de réflexion sur les libertés
je mentionne cette proposition à ce
moment parce que je voudrais en faire un
marqueur très fort ici au sénat qui est
précisément la vigie de nos libertés
publiques
car je crois qu'au fond tous les grands
enjeux que rencontre aujourd'hui notre
société y compris bien sûr avec cette
crise sanitaire peuvent être regardés
sous le prisme de la liberté vous le
voyez tout ce combat j'y crois c'est ce
qui m'anime
et c'est pourquoi je suis devant vous
cet après midi public sénat pour moi
c'est d'abord un choix de coeur et si je
brigue un nouveau mandat
c est avec modestie parce que je suis
convaincu que par ces temps orageux je
suis celui qui peut le mieux
allier la stabilité dont on a besoin
pour piloter ce média et l'innovation
indispensable pour qu'ils s'adaptent aux
défis nouveaux et qu il se réinvente
encore une fois dans cette crise aux
dimensions multiples je pense avoir la
meilleure connaissance de public sénat
du sénat et est de vous sénatrices et
sénateurs pour faire face aux enjeux qui
sont devant nous nous sommes à un
tournant à la fois notre vie politique
et de l'évolution de nos métiers de
l'information face aux autres le drapeau
public sénat doivent continuer de se
hisser plus haut toujours plus haut et
vous pouvez être certain si vous
m'accordez votre confiance je m'y engage
que j'accomplirai ma mission jusqu'au
bout pleinement sans regarder ailleurs
et je serai dans l'action immédiatement
notamment pour faire vivre cette
démocratie territoriale lors des
prochaines élections départementales et
régionales
ma passion est non seulement intacte
mais redoublé par ce qui nous attend je
suis tourné vers l'avenir
je préfère toujours agir en dix ans ce
sera mieux demain que c'était mieux
avant et avec vous c'est ce message
cette énergie cette volonté que je veux
communiquer aux équipes et à tous nos
publics
vous pouvez compter sur moi merci
monsieur kessler pour cette conclusion
sauf qu'à à ce que certains de mes
collègues et un mot complémentaire à
dire mais je pense que nous allons
pouvoir conclure effectivement cette
audition en vous remerciant voilà pour
l'audition d'emmanuel kessler président
sortant de public sénat pdg depuis 2015
deux autres candidats vont être
auditionnés ils n'ont rien vu rien
entendu des échanges qui se sont
déroulés pendant 40 minutes
car il était dans un bureau isolé sans
téléphone et cela pour respecter le
principe d'égalité entre tous les
candidats
je vous propose à présent de suivre
l'audition de damien fleurot
actuellement chef du service politique
de ces news et auparavant journaliste
politique sur bfm tv et chers collègues
nous reprenons nos travaux bonjour
monsieur fleurot
je vous rappelle les règles que j'ai
indiqué tout à l'heure déjà votre
audition a duré 40 minutes d'abord dix
minutes de présentation de votre
candidature
puis 25 minutes des changes avec la
commission et enfin 20 minutes pour
votre conclusion
et je vous donne donc la parole pour
commencer pour une durée de 10 minutes
monsieur fleurot vous avez la parole
donc madame la vice présidente monsieur
le vice président monsieur le capteur
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs
permettez-moi d'abord de vous dire
combien je suis honoré d'exposer devant
vous le projet que je porte au service
de public sénat et de son rayonnement en
tant que journaliste politique depuis
près de 20 ans j'ai notamment été en
charge de l'actualité parlementaire
j'ai donc pu mesurer de près la qualité
de vos travaux dans vos rapports dans
vos débats en séance ou en commission
mais j'ai aussi pu voir les exigences
d'une institution indépendante
transparente une institution qui cherche
toujours à conjuguer l'intelligence du
temps long à l'excellent du terme et la
chaîne public sénat doit en être le
reflet par ailleurs mon projet vous
invite aussi à regarder le rôle la place
la responsabilité de public sénat dont
le contexte médiatique et des mots 4 td
et démocratique actuel selon un récent
sondage
aujourd'hui un français sur trois ne
considère plus la démocratie comme le
meilleur système sur deux croit à
l'existence des illuminati ou encore
d'un complot sioniste mondiale fort de
ces constats
je vous propose de positionner
logiquement public sénat non pas comme
la chaîne des questions à toutes vos
réponses
selon le slogan actuelle je vous propose
de faire de public sénat la chaîne de la
confiance au service de votre actualité
parlementaire ici au palais du
luxembourg
et bien entendu sur le terrain dans vos
dés dans vos collectivités
pour bâtir cette offre j'ai beaucoup
regardé antenne consulter des personnes
de tous horizons et écoutez je me suis
appuyé sur mon expérience car les
chaînes d'information ont démontré ces
dernières années leur utilité auprès du
grand public et leurs capacités aussi à
innover dans le traitement des sujets
d'actualité public sénat depuis ses
débuts sous l'impulsion de jean pierre
elkabbach et jusqu'à aujourd'hui sous la
direction d'emmanuel kessler a mené de
nombreux chantiers mais j'ai la
conviction qu'il est aujourd'hui
possible nécessaire même pour public
sénat de renforcer la qualité de son
offre tout en élargissant son audience
public sénat
à 20 ans un âge où il est permis d'être
ambitieux audacieux et agile un exemple
parmi d'autres les médias qui traitent
de l'actualité politique n'ont pas
toujours le temps ni les moyens
d'envoyer une équipe ici au sénat suivre
vos travaux dans l'hémicycle ou en
commission
je propose que des vidéos prête à
diffuser tournés par des journalistes de
public sénat soit mise à disposition des
autres rédactions gracieusement un
rayonnement à peu de frais bruts par
exemple a parfaitement su le faire on
source on est on si dans ces contenus
largement repris cet exemple est le
reflet de mon projet je veux faire en
sorte que votre travail soit visible au
delà du seul canal 13 de la tnt
pourquoi se priver de la force d'autres
déclinaisons d'autres supports il ya des
partenaires que l'on connaît qui relaie
vos travaux et les travaux de public
sénat facebook twitter twitch mais il ya
aussi des collaborations à imaginer
demain avec par exemple
linkedin netflix
tous ces réseaux font l'événement en
mettant à disposition de plus en plus de
contenus d'information des interviews
des débats pour leurs dizaines de
millions d'abonnés en france
votre actualité les intéressent et fait
écho aux attentes des français vous
recevez ici des chefs d'entreprise des
partenaires sociaux la société civile
des représentants d'institutions clair
et donc par exemple défenseur des droits
il est auditionné demain devant la
commission des lois les libertés
publiques
une thématique forte vous le savez qui
fait l'actualité
autre point fondamental la fidélité des
équipes à la chaîne c'est une chance je
le crois il faut s'appuyer et
capitaliser sur cette force
j'entends être à l'écouté de tous les
collaborateurs particulièrement dans ce
contexte de crise sanitaire
alors que les mesures de télétravail
peuvent éloigner certains salariés
j'estime aussi que la gouvernance de
l'entreprise doit se faire avec vous
public sénat mais je vous dis peut
parfois vous semblait éloigner de votre
quotidien ou de votre agenda
à nous de créer ce lien plus direct pour
que vos informations
votre actualité soit d'abord traité sur
public sénat mieux valoriser et mieux
reprises
ce management par le dialogue doit se
faire naturellement dans le cadre d'une
exemplarité de la chaîne s'agissant de
sa politique des ressources humaines et
de sa gestion financière
au delà de ma formation en école de
commerce j'ai durant mon parcours
professionnel travailler dans un univers
audiovisuel concurrentiel avec une
rigueur budgétaire au centre de tout je
sais aussi que cela peut être une source
de créativité
quand on s'appuie sur la technologie je
pense par exemple à l'utilisation de
smartphones pour les tournages qui se
généralise dont les médias dans le monde
entier
concernant le lien avec la chaîne
parlementaire assemblée nationale
il est aujourd'hui je crois clair pour
tout le monde une mutualisation de
moyens quand cela est nécessaire mais
pas de fusion des entités ni des
rédactions
autre axe de mon projet je veux faire de
public sénat la chaîne de la citoyenneté
celle du civisme de la défense de la
laïcité de la lutte contre la
désinformation et les théories du
complot j'entends ouvrir un kiosque
digitale de ressources pédagogiques sur
votre travail accessible prioritairement
aux jeunes publics aux enseignants cet
espace pourrait être baptisée public
sénat 100% campus je n'invente rien cela
existe aux états unis avec le module de
la chaîne parlementaire américaine
si span class roule autre proposition
les journalistes de public sénat sont
chaque semaine sur le terrain ils
peuvent en profiter pour rencontrer des
classes et faire de l'éducation aux
médias
la vérification de l'information la
lutte contre le plan le complotisme
prend une place de plus en plus
importante
je peux créer un pôle dédié à cela est
une déclinaison à l'antenne c'est une
priorité de ces prochaines années
on s'en rendra compte dans les prochains
mois notamment à l'occasion de la
campagne présidentielle
je propose aussi de relancer un rendez
vous d'information en direct
en deuxième partie de soirée à 22 heures
il existait dans le passé quand il était
animé par sonia mabrouk un rendez-vous
au sein duquel les partenaires de la
presse locale aurait toute leur place
pour présenter l'actualité notamment
celle du lendemain
un temps d'avancé aussi sur public sénat
mais j'estime également opportun de
programmer la grande émission politique
hebdomadaire le dimanche quand les
français ont le temps pour regarder ce
type de rendez vous public sénat a 20
ans et ne doit avoir aucun complexe
vis-à-vis de ses concurrents
enfin la singularité de public sénat
passe nécessairement par un traitement
de votre actualité dans vos départements
le nombre de tournages a été réduit ces
dernières années je recommande qui leur
prennent une place plus conséquente à
l'antenne surtout dans un contexte de
campagne électorale
il convient de profiter du maillage
unique des partenaires de la presse
locale en sachant mieux valoriser
peut-être mieux événementialité cette
production et je tiens aussi à parler
d'europe
cette actualité aujourd'hui est traité
depuis bruxelles
mais elle doit l'être aussi je pense sur
le terrain je propose un rendez-vous qui
s'appellerait l'europe près de chez vous
la stratégie numérique et le dernier axe
de ma présentation elle doit résolument
être amplifiées dynamiser pour la
réussir public sénat doit parler
plusieurs langues
les codes d'instagram de twitter de
twitch de club house ne sont pas les
mêmes il faut faire des choix éditoriaux
et proposer du contenu dédié pour mieux
toucher chacune de ces communautés
il convient de repenser l'offre du site
internet
est ce utile pertinent d'avoir 9060
vidéos archivées
aujourd'hui et 55 mille articles rendant
fastidieux d'ailleurs la recherche
il faut à mon sens aujourd'hui être plus
sélectifs offensif aussi sur ce que l'on
appelle le preview ce sont des
programmes accessibles en ligne
en amont de leur diffusion par exemple
sur le canal 13 de la tnt pour faire
l'événement est aussi pour créer du lien
avec la communauté de public sénat
ce lien passe aussi par la création
d'une série de podcasts signé public
sénat un nouveau format audio plus long
permettant l'approfondissement le
premier sujet pourrait par exemple
traiter de l'actualité en nouvelle
calédonie et de l'avenir institutionnel
de ce territoire un mot pour conclure
public sénat le canal 13 de la tnt doit
demeurer vous l'avez compris le vaisseau
amiral mais public sénat doit être plus
que cela
public sénat doit être un média
conquérant qui se décline et se déploie
avec force ambitions et agilité une
chaîne attentive à son public
ancré dans tous les territoires à votre
écoute une chaîne qui conjugue qualité
de l'information diversité et pluralité
des débats publics sénat doit être la
chaîne de la confiance
voilà la route que j'entends tracé pour
ces prochaines années
si vous me faites l'honneur de diriger
cette entreprise je vous remercie je
suis à votre disposition pour répondre
merci beaucoup monsieur fleurot et nous
enchaînons sans attendre donc avec la
série de questions réponses et c'est
madame benbassa qui va commencer cet
exercice
monsieur fleurot selon vous quels sont
les principaux enjeux et des filles du
public sénat dans le paysage audiovisuel
actuelle comment définiriez-vous ses
missions intrinsèque
qu'est ce qui la différencie des autres
chaînes en particulier les chaînes
d'information mais aussi lcp assemblée
nationale public sénat
je voulais dit effectivement doit parler
plusieurs langues et se déployait sur
plusieurs supports
aujourd'hui public sénat concentre ses
moyens sur le canal 13 de la tnt
je pense qu'il est important de
conserver ce mode de diffusion et j'en
fait mention dans mon rapport mais
public sénat doit se montrer plus
offensif et plus agile dans des
collaborations avec d'autres supports je
pense par exemple à certains réseaux
sociaux je pense par exemple à des
plateformes qui aujourd'hui se lance et
propose du contenu parfois plus ciblées
par exemple des plateformes qui propose
des documentaires
il faut des biens densifier ses
partenariats afin que l'image de public
sénat qui est aujourd'hui bien reconnu
des français bien puisse toucher un plus
large public
vous l'avez vu dans mon dossier public
c'est là et c'est peut-être ce qui peut
la démarquer des chaînes d'information
et bien c'est l'enjeu sur la citoyenneté
l'enjeu sur la démocratie
je pense que public sénat doit s'ouvrir
doit s'ouvrir aux français et plus
particulièrement
au jeune public c'est pour cette raison
que je propose la création d'un kiosque
digital avec des modules expliquant de
façon très pédagogique votre travail et
vous pourriez être acteur de ce kiosque
vos collaborateurs les journalistes de
public sénat
également je pense aussi que public
sénat doit aller à la rencontre de son
public
et cela passe notamment peut-être par
ses interventions dans des
établissements scolaires ou les
journalistes de public sénat viendrait
expliquer leur métier le journalisme
politique pour lutter contre l' les
fakes news la désinformation mais
également pour parler de votre
institution le sénat merci je donne la
parole à madame eustache brinio pour la
deuxième question oui alors vous avez
abordé légèrement ce sujet mais je
voulais vous demander si vous pensez
qu'il fallait effectivement faire
évoluer les modalités diffusion de
public sénat sur la tnt je pense que sam
raimi j'aimerais bien qu'on revienne sur
ce sujet et si oui à quelles conditions
et surtout à quel horizon faudrait-il le
fer avec quels modes alternatifs de
diffusion à privilégier je pense que
c'est important aujourd'hui à des
innovations à faire évidemment avec un
objectif à la fois de diversification et
de renforcement de l'audience de la
chaîne
je pense que le mode de diffusion liée à
la tnt est un mode de diffusion à
conserver il représente un coût
important certes mais aujourd'hui un peu
plus de 22 % des foyers c'est un chiffre
qui date du premier semestre 2001 donc
que ce seul mode de réception et je ne
recommande pas s'en priver
parce que c'est un mode de réception
important qui de plus est de surcroît
est gratuit pour les personnes qui
regardent la télévision par ce biais
public sénat doit rester accessible au
plus grand nombre mais ne doit pas se
priver de décliner ses contenus les
productions de public sénat sur toute
une série de supports et là je pense
qu'il faut être offensif agile aussi je
vous ai parlé de plateformes vidéo qui
propose des par exemple des
documentaires du le reportage
je vous parle bien entendu des réseaux
sociaux qui diffusent de plus en plus de
contenu en direct ou en différé
et je vous ai parlé du réseau par
exemple d'une cuisine qu'ils recherchent
ici par exemple quand vous recevez dans
le cadre de commissions et bien des
personnalités il pourrait y avoir un
pont entre entre public sénat et cette
passerelle pour atteindre un public qui
ne vient peut-être pas naturellement sur
le canal 13 de la tnt
si la parole est à madame nathalie
delattre
merci madame la présidente monsieur
floraux dans un contexte budgétaire
contraint comment comptez-vous mettre en
valeur à l'antenne de public sénat tous
les territoires y compris les outre-mer
et rendre compte de l'activité de
terrain des sénatrices et sénateurs dans
l'exercice de leur mandat
par ailleurs comment comptez vous
assurer l'égalité femmes hommes à
l'antenne
merci merci pour votre question
effectivement je pars ma carrière de
journaliste du journaliste politique
j'ai j'ai sillonné la france en suivant
des responsables politiques
en faisant du reportage et je sais que
cette emprise ce lien avec le terrain
est fondamental c'est une des
particularités de la chaîne public sénat
qui offre à la fois un traitement de
votre actualité en plateau sur des
tranches bien particulière mais
également qui permet de suivre vos
travaux dans les territoires il y a un
lien et j'en ai parlé dans mon exposé
avec les groupes de la presse
quotidienne régionale
ils produisent énormément de contenu des
vidéos d'une grande qualité et je pense
qu'il doit y avoir peut-être un
partenariat renforcé à ce sujet pour
ancrer un peu plus la présence des
territoires à l'antenne il ira ensuite
des émissions qui existent aujourd'hui
qui vous suivent dans votre quotidien et
qui viennent parfois pendant plusieurs
jours et bien comprendre les réalités
que vous rencontrez dans l'est dans les
départements concernant l'égalité hommes
femmes aujourd'hui
et bien c'est un sujet qui a été je
dirais pris en main par emmanuel kessler
ces dernières années des rendez-vous
d'information notamment à l'antenne sont
présentées par des femmes
c'est bien entendu et bien une priorité
que j'entendais poursuivre si on me
confie la direction de l'entreprise
il y à une évolution sous votre
impulsion une évolution de législatif et
j'entends être être particulièrement
écart à l'affût sur ce sujet sur le
sujet de la diversité également sur le
sujet de l'inclusion le handicape
également ici merci monsieur fleurot
alors je vais poser la question suivante
à ce jour vous avez effectué l'ensemble
de votre carrière dans les chaînes
d'information pourriez vous nous
expliquer en quoi votre expérience
professionnelle vous permettrait de
présider une chaîne de service public
comme public sénat
et pensez vous que c'est la même
approche que celle des chaînes
d'information que nous devons chercher
pour public sénat sinon comment concevez
vous justement cette mue c'est vrai que
j'ai travaillé au sein de bfm tv et de
ses news donc dans un univers de des
chaînes d'information en continu et je
pense que mon expérience de journaliste
politique expérimenté est un atout pour
public sénat de comprendre les enjeux
aujourd'hui de comprendre votre
quotidien de comprendre presque de
l'intérieur en ayant suivi vos travaux
l'actualité parlementaire
je pense que dans la période qui s'ouvre
c'est nécessaire afin de porter je
dirais un projet une vision d'entreprise
pour pour public sénat
et c'est d'ailleurs une tradition que
cette chaîne soit dirigée par par un
journaliste
j'ai par ailleurs dans les
responsabilités encadrer des équipes
l'ont breuses parfois sur le sur le
terrain qui se déployait partout dans
les territoires
j'ai été en lien avec bien entendu
l'organisation de l'antenne et la
direction de mes entreprises pour mettre
en place des opérations spéciales des
des dispositifs aujourd'hui je veux
passer entre guillemets une nouvelle
étape dans dans ma carrière et donc
diriger une entreprise comme public
sénat c'est pour cette raison que je
suis ici devant vous vous m'avez demandé
la voilà la mue entre guillemets c'est
voilà ce passage que je souhaite que je
souhaite faire très bien merci monsieur
fleurot la parole est à monsieur joël
guerriau merci bien le présente monsieur
l'euro en prenant connaissance de votre
dossier de candidature j'étais surpris
agréablement surpris d'abord parce que
j'ai trouvé que la présentation était
tout à fait intéressante et surtout
parce que vous avez là on fait
énormément de propositions qui sont très
bien argumenté
alors je me dis que ce long terme sur le
plan de la ligne journalistique vous
avez du contenu et vous avez une
connaissance réelle et sérieuse
la question qui m'interpelle c'est la
question de la fonction à laquelle vous
postulez qui est une fonction qui
demande
ces qualités vous avez su nous montrer à
travers cette candidature mais aussi des
qualités de gestionnaire pourquoi parce
que public sénat c'est aussi un budget
annuel de 18 millions d'euros
et sur ce point là cette expérience ne
ressort pas de votre doigt de parcours
et j'aimerais avoir votre vision sur ce
qui vous paraît très de nature à
améliorer la gestion de public sénat
merci aussi pour votre question
effectivement
je n'ai pas eu la responsabilité d'un
tel d'une j'ai dans ma carrière et
jusqu'ici et je mesure l'importance de
cette question
public sénat fonctionne dans un univers
budgétaire contraint en lien avec avec
vous bien entendu la dotation que vous
salou et à l'entreprise constitue
quasiment l'essentiel de ces de ses
ressources
il y à des leviers sans doute à activer
ils le sont déjà et on peut les
amplifier je pense aux partenariats au
parrainage d'émissions qui offre des
recettes
alors bien entendu la situation
économique est elle aussi sous tension
et il faudra être sans doute offensive
pour nouer de nouvelles collaborations
je pense aussi et c'est mon expérience
en chaîne d'information qui m'a apporté
sans doute et bien cette cette qualité
là ces deux d'être à l'affût de
nouvelles technologies qui nous
permettent des économies en quelque
sorte je vous ai parlé par exemple de
l'utilisation de smartphones pour filmer
des reportages c'est un outil qui est
d'ailleurs et parfois et bien sans doute
plus opportun parce que moins intrusif
auprès des personnes que l'on rencontre
l'utilisation du téléphone portable se
généralise et moins coûteux que l'achat
de caméra parfois donc je pense assez
assez assez mutation je connais
effectivement cet univers budgétaire
contraint qui est celui de public sénat
aujourd'hui mais qui est aussi celui des
chaînes dans lequel j'ai pu travailler
c'est pierre laurent oui bonjour
monsieur fleurot dans votre projet vous
avez vous évoqué et vous venez d'en
évoquer certaines toute une série de
pistes innovantes sur les contenus et
les partenariats
vous avez parlé tout à l'heure de
signature de programmes diffusés à
l'antenne de
dispositif nouveau pour travailler avec
les jeunes publics et parmi les pistes
d'évolution vous évoquez il ya une piste
en matière de documentaire vous avez
aussi parlé de partenariat en la manière
en la matière et vous proposer notamment
d'investir le terrain de l'ado qui joue
aussi de la docu fiction en repensant
les formes alors que l'on constate que
les mini série rencontre un grand succès
sur certaines plateformes est ce que
vous pourriez nous en dire plus sur
cette piste innovantes que vous
souhaitez développer
c'est vrai que le documentaire est un
format qui rencontre un vrai succès sur
l'antenne de public sénat et certains
documentaires longs l'entrée récemment
je pense qu'il faut poursuivre cette
politique qui a été engagée en lien
notamment avec la chaîne parlementaire
assemblée nationale peut être dans une
mutualisation de coproduction ou en tous
les cas dans un agenda coordonnées de
thématiques a à traiter je pense qu'il
faut effectivement suivre les évolutions
aussi de consommation de deux reportages
documentaires de série aussi les
français adhèrent à des séries passent
beaucoup de temps devant leur écran et
c'est vrai que les formats que l'on peut
connaître en télévision je dirais les
formats classiques 26 minutes où 52
minutes sont aujourd'hui peut-être à
revisiter sans rien retirer de la
qualité et du fond du projet il peut y
avoir aussi et bien un nouveau découpage
qui amène
nouvelle forme d'écriture aussi afin de
mieux coller aux attentes des
téléspectateurs et notamment des jeunes
publics
j'ai parlé aussi de de la possibilité de
mettre en preview certains programmes
afin de d'événements si alizée l'antenne
la mise en ligne de certaines séries se
fait beaucoup et permet de voilà de de
toucher un autre public d'événements sia
lisez la sortie d'un document de créer
du lien avec la communauté
merci monsieur fleurot il nous reste
encore du temps puisque vous avez 40
minutes ce que je propose à mes
collègues c'est de poser peut-être une
ou deux questions complémentaires en
fonction du temps disponible monsieur
capo-canellas maires des six ans mercy
m'a pas dit dans plusieurs jours vous
avez évoqué le salaire les relations
avec notre consoeur lcp avec laquelle
nous partageons le canal et j'ai noté la
formule mutualisation de moyens n'est
pas fusion alors que vous pouvez
préciser un petit peu ce que vous
entendez par là
notamment on a un arrière-plan nous la
question que pose souvent l'assemblée ou
de la condition qui nous semble qu'elle
pose c'est à dire qu'elle a tendance à
regarder la mutualisation des moyens
comme devant être à manga bleu menthe
associée à une utilisation éditoriale
est là pour le coup ça pose le problème
des spécificités de la chaîne que nous
souhaitons défendre
alors voilà qu'est ce que vous voyez là
dessus et puis deuxièmement vous avez
parlé des smartphones tout à l'heure
quelle est la limite à l'usagé des
smartphones parce que forcément il ya
des personnes et qui sont aujourd'hui
j'y ai ri et pour la chaîne comment vous
voyez tout ça effectivement
mutualisation des moyens et c'est à dire
une collaboration dans l'achat par
exemple de matériel dans la coproduction
parfois de d'événements il y à un des
rendez-vous qui sont réguliers à
l'antenne qui permettent aux deux
chaînes de travailler ensemble
il peut y avoir aussi à l'avenir des
événements sur le terrain qui peuvent
nous permettre de travailler ensemble
public sénat et la chaîne parlementaire
assemblée nationale mais fusion des
rédactions fusion des management je
pense effectivement que ce n'est pas à
l'ordre du jour
ce n'est pas ce qui est souhaité ici
d'ailleurs et vous me l'avez tous dit
dans les échanges que j'ai pu avoir
tout simplement parce qu'il y a et on
l'a vu dans l'actualité récente une
spécificité
je dirais à vos travaux une singularité
ici public sénat
a aussi un lien particulier avec la
presse quotidienne régionale c'est un
c'est un axe très fort de développement
des programmes et et c'est ce qui
singularise je pense le l'entreprise
alors concernant l'utilisation des
smartphones moi je pense que
effectivement certains types de tournage
ne le recommande pas il faut savoir
adapter l'outil à la réalisation et il y
a
par contre des moments où l' usage d'une
voie là d'un téléphone portable
parce qu'il est moins imposant moins
intrusif permet de deux d'aller à la
rencontre des français dans une intimité
à la rencontre des des personnes que
l'on souhaite mettre à l'image
il ya une émission qui est aujourd'hui
diffusée sur l'antenne de public sénat
qui s'appelle terre à terre et qui est
tourné aussi avec des smartphones la
qualité de l'image
aujourd'hui a fait de très nets progrès
ce n'était pas le cas auparavant
et je pense bien entendu que dans une
discussion bien avec les salariés les
journaliste reporter d'imagés bien une
petit à voir
l'utilisation de ces outils merci et
monsieur hervé vous avez évoqué la
question européenne et la question d'une
une émission dédiée ce que vous pouvez
nous en dire davantage c'est une une
question auxquelles les sénateurs autre
ère de leurs délégations falloir
commission même aux affaires européennes
comme au travers du travail
parlementaire lui même sont
particulièrement attachés comment vous
voyez cette émission je pense que vous
l'avez en plus rattaché un peu au
territoire est ce que vous pouvez nous
en dire davantage oui c'est vrai qu'on
aujourd'hui l'émission qui traite de
l'actualité européenne est réalisée
depuis bruxelles en plateau en
partenariat avec france 24 ce qui permet
et bien d'être en prise directe avec
cette actualité mais qui ne permet pas
de retranscrire la réalité sans doute de
l'activité européenne et de l'actualité
européenne sur les territoires dans les
départements au plus près des français
je propose effectivement une nouvelle
émission qui aborde cette question sous
cet angle là c'est à dire de quelle
façon et bien concrètement les décisions
qui peuvent être prises au niveau
européen ont des répercussions un impact
c'est pour ça que j'ai intitulé cette
émission l'europe près de près de chez
moi
je pense que ça
c'est une façon là aussi de mieux rendre
compte de cette actualité des travaux du
parlement européen de la commission
on le voit aujourd'hui à l'occasion de
la crise sanitaire
l'europe l'a dit bruxelles peut sembler
déconnecté des préoccupations des
français et s'interroger avec un ancrage
local sur cette thématique là permet
sans doute permettrait sans doute voilà
de rapprocher l'institution européenne
des réalités des préoccupations des
français
merci plus de questions peut-être
rapidement comme il vous reste encore un
petit moment
une petite question pour conclure
l'année 2022 va être une année
particulière pour les rédactions
pourriez vous nous dire comment vous
avez envisageriez son traitement 2022 et
est marqué par ce rendez vous avec
l'élection présidentielle auparavant il
y aura d'autres fretin qui vous
concernent d'ailleurs je pense aux
régionales ou départementales un
renouvellement sénatorial
on voit deux mois de septembre mais
c'est vrai que le rendez-vous
présidentiel sera forcément un moment
fort de l'antenne de public sénat
j'entends d'ailleurs
le vivre avec cet angle du local du
terrain des préoccupations des français
qui vont chercher à exprimer des des
envies à exprimer des idées et à la
rédaction de public sénat d'être au plus
près de 2 des français pour faire vivre
justement ce débat d'idées en lien avec
vous effectivement où il pourrait y
avoir des opérations de dialogue entre
parlementaires et les les français afin
et bien justement de de ceux de se
démarquer peut-être des chaînes
d'information en continu qui traiteront
de cette actualité sous un prisme plus
lié au débat de plateau je dirais public
sénat avec la chaîne parlementaire
assemblée nationale doit également se
positionner sur des rendez vous je pense
aux débats aux interviews des candidats
c'est l'évènement marquant politique de
2022 et il faudra se positionner à ce
niveau là très bien monsieur fleurot et
maintenant il vous reste à conclure
effectivement votre intervention dans la
limite de 40 minutes qui sont impartis à
chaque candidat
vous avez la parole monsieur madame la
présidente
mesdames messieurs les sénateurs je
souhaite donc vous redire l'honneur qui
est le mien de présenter mon projet pour
public sénat je suis ici à l'issue d'un
processus de sélection ouvert
transparent qui est à l'image de ce
qu'incarne le sénat vous êtes
la chambre de l'indépendance de l'ecoute
ou le temps long des débats permet
souvent d'être en avance sur son temps
la chambre de l'équilibré des pouvoirs
et de une chambre qui est résolument
proche des français et de leur quotidien
une chambre bien en prise avec la
société ces évolutions que vous
accompagnez si vous m'avez donné la
possibilité de défendre la vision que je
porte pour public sénat
c'est justement parce que vous jugez
sans doute qu'il y a des choses à
changer et que je peux par mon
expérience mes idées continuer à faire
grandir la chaîne qui vous représente la
faire grandir avec les équipes de public
sénat
j'y ai beaucoup réfléchi cette décision
de me présenter à la présidence de
public sénat a gelé prise en conscience
avec modestie mais avec beaucoup de
détermination
est ce que je souhaite vous dire c'est
que je suis certes un journaliste
politique met pas un journaliste
partisans je ne serai pas le président
d'un camp mais celui qui défend une
institution la vôtre et chacun de ses
représentants dans leur diversité
certains d'entre vous me découvre
aujourd'hui d'autres m'ont vu sur le
terrain et à l'antenne connaissent mon
engagement et ma rigueur que je souhaite
investir à 100 % pur public sénat ma
candidature au poste de président
directeur général s'inscrit dans la
tradition de cette chaîne d'avoir choisi
des journalistes pour la diriger
maîtriser les codes de l'actualité vous
connaître presque de l'intérieur pour
porter une vision éditorial adapté
particulièrement dans cette période
troublée est en effet essentiel pour une
chaîne qui fait de l'actualité politique
et parlementaire
le coeur de son antenne public sénat à
20 ans aujourd'hui
si la marque est bien ancrée dans
l'esprit des français
la chaîne n'a sans doute pas été
suffisamment prescriptrices des
changements ces dernières années à bfm
tv et j'ai participé à la création de la
chaîne en 2005 en étant au coeur des
mutations qui marque encore maintenant
le paysage audiovisuel et de la même
façon depuis deux ans et demi à ses news
eh bien j'ai vu cette chaîne qui a su
partir à la conquête d'un nouveau public
avec les débats d'opinion
il ne s'agit pas et vous l'avez compris
de copier ses chaînes d'information mais
à public sénat d'être maintenant aussi
ambitieuse en conservant sa singularité
son identité vis-à-vis de la chaîne
parlementaire assemblée nationale avec
des programmes renouvelée en utilisant
de nouveaux outils de façon à gilles et
en repensant l'offre digitale avec une
équipe dédiée pour toucher un public
plus jeune et plus large
je m'engage à réaliser ce projet en
associant pleinement les collaborateurs
de public sénat
la rédaction ne met d'ailleurs pas
inconnu j'ai été amené à travailler avec
certains journalistes
ces chantiers seront menées en relation
approfondie avec les partenaires
historiques de la chaîne
les représentants de la presse
quotidienne régionale en particulier de
la presse spécialisée aussi des radios
et des télévisions locales
j'ai déjà pris des contacts et je sais
qu'il y a une volonté partagée d'innover
et d'aller plus loin dans l'exploration
de nouveaux champs d'expression on de
renouer plus fortement avec la
thématique de la culture ou celle du
patrimoine par exemple public sénat et
pour tous ces acteurs soyez en persuader
une opportunité
mon projet vous l'avez compris est une
promesse de confiance confiance de
public sénat
avec toutes ses parties prenantes en
indépendance mais aussi confiance pour
faire de public sénat
un acteur résolument ancré dans l'avenir
de l'audiovisuel
voilà la route que j'entends tracé je
vous remercie
merci pour cette conclusion monsieur
fleurot et nous avons donc terminer
votre audition
voilà pour l'audition de damien fleurot
qui est actuellement chef du service
politique de ces news et auparavant qui
était journaliste politique à bfm tv
on va à présent passer à la troisième et
dernière audition de l'après midi le
dernier candidat auditionné pour la
présidence de public sénat et
christopher baldelli ancien directeur
général de france 2 puis patron de rtl
de 2009 à 2019 nous reprenons nos
travaux et monsieur bell les lie je vous
rappelle les règles que j'ai indiqué
tout à l'heure déjà votre audition a
duré 40 minutes d'abord dix minutes de
présentation de votre candidature
puis 25 minutes des changes avec la
commission et puis pour terminer cinq
minutes environ pour votre conclusion
je vous donne donc maintenant la parole
sans attente pour une durée de 10
minutes monsieur bel élu aux îles madame
la présidente monsieur le questeur
mesdames les sénatrices mesdames les
sénateurs messieurs les sénateurs votre
chaîne public sénat
aujourd'hui a déjà 20 ans je me souviens
qu'il y a 20 ans en avril 2020 je signe
et je négocier comme dirigeants de
france 2 ce qui était un premier
protocole d'accord avec ce qui
s'appelait encore à l'époque la chaîne
parlementaire sénat et depuis vingt ans
on le sait tous beaucoup de choses
ce sens passé en général et dans le
secteur médias en particulier cette
chaîne bien sûr a touché sa fréquence
tnt en 2006 qui lui a donné une
visibilité une notoriété extrêmement
importante mais aussi durant cette
période on a vu la multiplication du
nombre de chaînes gratuites
on a vu la multiplication du nombre de
chaînes d'information et on a vu
naturellement l'avènement du numérique
et des réseaux sociaux et dans cet
environnement multiples hyper
concurrentiel d'une certaine façon ne
pas évoluer suffisamment vite c'est déjà
prendre le risque de reculer et je crois
que cette chaîne a aujourd'hui besoin
d'un souffle nouveau
je pense qu'elle a besoin d'un nouvel
élan et je vais essayer de vous
présenter mon projet à travers les
quatre axes qui vous ont qui vous sont
présentés le premier de ces axes
consiste à bien définir à la fois le
positionnement et la spécificité de
cette chaîne en effet face à ce nouvel
environnement hyper confidences hyper
concurrentiel il faut bien que public
sénat réussissent à préserver à défendre
son identité
on sait qu'aujourd'hui beaucoup de
médias et par exemple les chaînes
d'infos dans cette surenchère ont
tendance à hausser le ton je pense au
contraire que public sénat peut
parfaitement être le lieu d'un dialogue
d'un dialogue constructif d'un dialogue
apaisé et civilisé c'est un espace
possible dans l'univers audiovisuel
français public sénat et la chaîne du
sénat
je vous apprendrai pas grand chose mais
cela veut dire très concrètement pour
son positionnement pour son identité
qu'elle doit naturellement traiter de
l'actualité mais qu'elle doit surtout
traiter de l'actualité du sénat et
parler des territoires pour cela elle
doit faire son travail de chaînes
parlementaires
je dirais sans complexe et même en le
revendiquant parler des territoires on
le sait la france ne se résume pas à
paris les territoires sont multiples
variées urbains ruraux en métropole et
dans les territoires d'outre-mer
les français ont les goûts de ses
territoires on le sait il suffit de voir
le succès de certains journaux
quotidiens à la télévision qui en
donnent largement compte et qui ont un
succès extrêmement important je crois
donc pour cette chaîne parler des
territoires c'est en vérité un atout et
une distinction pour public sénat sur la
chaîne sénatoriales on doit voir et
entendre des sénateurs et des sénatrices
bien évidemment on doit aller voir comme
dans leurs activités à paris ou dans
leur territoire
on doit également les avoir comme
invités comme expert dans les émissions
quotidiennes et on doit également les
avoir comme invitée dans ces mêmes
émissions quotidiennes
chaque année l'ensemble des 348
sénatrices et sénateurs doit avoir au
moins une exposition sur un des médias
de public sénat
tel est mon engagement parler des
territoires traiter de l'actualité du
sénat l'actualité parlementaire ce n'est
pas à vous que je dirais celle du sénat
est permanente
le travail des commissions le travail
législatif les commission denquête
l'émission d'information le travail des
délégations les questions d'actualité au
gouvernement
c'est une matière extrêmement riche
extrêmement dense il est d'ailleurs sans
doute elle est tellement dense sans
doute peut-être difficile en permanence
de de savoir tout ce qui se passe mais
c'est le rôle de cette rédaction c'est
le rôle de cette chaîne et pour moi
c'est au coeur de sa mission le sénat de
son côté a repensé au cours des
dernières années l'organisation de ces
travaux à travers notamment une
modernisation de ses rapports
l'accroissement des captations des
auditions qui naturellement constituent
une matière première précieuse pour
cette chaîne est également le
développement des travaux de contrôle
cela a permis à cette assemblée de mieux
interagir avec les attentes des citoyens
eh bien je crois qu'aujourd'hui public
sénat devrait m'en faire le lien entre
ces travaux et ses attentes et faciliter
l'accès à l'information
je vais vous donner un exemple simple
chaque semaine le sénat des sénateurs
font des propositions qui intéresse tous
les français dans leur vie
tidiane et bien il faut que cela soit
l'antenne de public sénat dans un
programme qui pourrait s'intituler par
exemple le sénat et vous la publie la
chaîne public sénat
toujours dans ce positionnement est en
finirait sur ce point là doit être une
chaîne citoyenne elle doit être un
rempart pour la démocratie
représentative par rapport à la
démocratie d'opinion
c'est une façon pour la chaîne de faire
voir sa différence par rapport aux
médias publics et privés notamment parce
qu'elle a une exigence légale
d'impartialité elle est la seule en
france à la boire et c'est précieux je
pense à un moment où les médias on le
sait ont de plus en plus de mal à faire
face à la défiance du public à leur
égard le deuxième axe vise à apporter à
la chaîne au programme une visibilité
une modernité plus forte sur ce point là
je pense qu'il doit y avoir des
évolutions à la fois sur la forme et sur
le fond je dirais que les programmes et
c'est peut-être leur travers de public
sénat sont parfois un peu trop sérieux
je ne parle pas du fond je parle de la
forme
or nous sommes dans un monde de la
télévision qui est ainsi fait que la
concurrence est forte que les choix sont
multiples et donc il est extrêmement
important d'être dans les bons codes de
télévision que ce soit pour la décor
pour la narration pour la réalisation
pour le rythme des évolutions des
émissions tout cela évolue très vite et
même si la chaîne public sénat est
différent elle ne peut pas faire
l'économie dans sa proposition de cette
modernité dans son identité visuelle
je donnerai juste à titre d'exemple le
fait qu'aujourd'hui les visages qui
incarne l'écran elle a toujours été un
endroit pour faire découvrir des
nouveaux talents
c'est son adn d'origine mais il n'y a
pas aujourd'hui véritablement de figure
identifié du grand public or ces figures
identifiés ont l'intérêt d'amener plus
facilement d'identifier la chaîne de
donner confiance au public alors
entendons-nous bien il s'agit pas de
faire la course aux stars ce n'est ni
dans les budgets ni dans l'esprit de la
chaîne mais dans le passé ça a été le
cas il ya eu des personnalités reconnues
de l'audiovisuel qui sont venus dans un
projet qui les intéressait enfin je
pense que en ce qui concerne les experts
et journalistes invités à l'antenne
il faudra continuer à travailler sur un
profil plus diversifiée et notamment
prenant mieux en compte la diversité
en ce qui concerne les deux principales
émissions quotidiennes de la chaîne
l'émission de la matinale bonjour chez
vous et celle allons plus loin je crois
que parce que justement elles sont
largement diffusés sur la chaîne
il est important de les faire évoluer
pour qu'elle soit encore plus riche et
plus dense et naturellement public sénat
doit être plus que jamais la chaîne des
territoires et donc les partenariats
noués avec l'uni et lou parlons ici mois
les partenariats lient avec la presse
quotidienne régionale avec les radios en
région doivent aussi à mon sens être
approfondies janvier un présent au
troisième axe celui concerne la volonté
d'accentuer l'empreinte numérique de la
chaîne notamment sur les réseaux sociaux
en temps non bien aujourd'hui le premier
canal de diffusion de cette chaîne c'est
bien sûr le canal tnt
et naturellement il faut le privilégié
mais on sait que les l'évolution et
l'avenir de la tnt sont des choses
qu'ils ne sont pas à ce stade totalement
prévisibles il faut donc continuer à
investir fortement sur les autres modes
de diffusion et notamment sur les modes
de diffusion numérique
donc je pense qu'il faut des formats
plus variés sur cet univers là et je
propose donc une stratégie fondée sur la
marque public sénat favorisant une hyper
distribution des programmes afin de
rattraper notamment un retard sur les
réseaux sociaux et sur les applications
sur les réseaux sociaux je constate que
le sénat commun comme assembler à une
avance notamment sur twitter
dans une audience très large je constate
au contraire que la chaîne public sénat
notamment par rapport à son homologue
lcp de l'assemblée nationale n'a pas
nécessairement la tête mais même
performance sur ses raisons donc je
pense que sur ses réseaux pour améliorer
la performance
il y à une grammaire propre il faut pas
se contenter beaucoup de rediffuser les
problèmes linéaire mais il faut
véritablement faire des formats et des
programmes spécifiques pour ces réseaux
c'est comme ça qu'on trouvera davantage
de résonance et c'est important
notamment vis-à-vis des publics jeunes
vous le savez j'observe aussi que la
chaîne n'a pas de mobilité
d'applications en mobilité je pense que
c'est un sujet qui doit être en tout cas
examinés
et enfin toujours dans l'empreinte
numérique et pour finir sur ce point là
je dirais il ya une initiative à mon
sens ce qui peut être pris qui pourrait
s'appeler public local et qui
constituerait à faire une plateforme
agglomérant des programmes de la chaîne
elle même en territoire en région et
également des programmes de ses
partenaires de la pqr la chaîne ayant un
rôle à ce moment-là d'agrégateur de
partenaires sur ce sujet et j'en viens
enfin à mon dernier axe qui concerne le
projet d'entreprise
je dirais premier point nous ont
peut-être l'occasion d'en parler
ce projet doit être fait à budget
constant mais pour cela je les dis il
faut prendre des nouvelles initiatives
numériques des nouvelles initiatives sur
les programmes
donc je propose une méthode on pourra
l'aider de la détailler si vous voulez
qu'ils s'appellent budget base zéro et
qui permet en vérité de réexaminer
toutes les dépenses en se reposant
permanence la question de leur fondement
mais une chaîne ce n'est pas seulement
des coûts c'est aussi des personnes qui
travaillent c'est une valeur ajoutée
très forte de cette chaîne est
évidemment un réseau de talent j'entends
bien je les fais tout dans tous les
entreprises que j'ai dirigé être le
garant de la paix sociale pour
l'ensemble des équipes de public sénat
et enfin je finirai sur ce point là
au-delà des enjeux naturellement de
parité de diversité fondamental pour
cette chaîne de par son âge même la
question de l'exigence de l'aide de
toute forme de lutte contre les
violences sexuelles au travail
au delà de tout ça si on veut se
redonner des marges de manoeuvre je
crois qu'il faut remettre sur la table
le travail de synergie avec la chaîne de
l'assemblée nationale lcp entendons nous
bien pas des synergies des
rapprochements à n'importe quel coup je
dis très clairement et cela figure dans
mon projet que la fusion n'est pas dans
mon projet et je ne suis pas l'homme qui
fera la fusion d'ailleurs ça ne dépend
pas du président de la chaîne mais ça
dépend d'abord des instances de la de
l'assemblée mais je veux dire que si on
veut retrouver des marges de manoeuvre
il ya sans doute moyen de relancer un
processus de coopération qui aujourd'hui
me semble proche
disons de l'immobilisme du point zéro et
je m'engagerai en tout cas a relancé une
démarche
constructive sur ce terrain là merci
merci monsieur bell délit et donc sans
plus attendre nous allons passer à la
série de questions réponses
elle va durer environ 25 minutes et
c'est madame fillol qui va poser la
première question oui merci madame la
présidente
cher monsieur vous avez déjà évoqué ces
sujets dans votre présentation mais je
me permets d'y revenir pour vous quels
sont les principaux enjeux et défis de
public sénat dans le paysage audiovisuel
actuelle comment définiriez-vous ses
missions intrinsèque et qu'est ce qui la
différencie des autres chaînes en
particulier les chaînes d'information
mais également lcp assemblée nationale
dont vous venez juste de parler
merci beaucoup merci madame la sénatrice
donc sur le premier point je finis juste
de noter votre troisième question
les principaux enjeux clairement si je
devais il y en a beaucoup naturellement
mais je vais aller sur les principaux le
premier je les dis aujourd'hui cette
chaîne à une fréquence tnt c'est
extrêmement précieux mais la tnt n'a pas
un avenir sans limite
il ya sans doute un rendez vous prévu
dès 2025 et il pourrait y avoir une
extension de la tnt en 2030 donc je
pense qu'il est plus que jamais
indispensable de vraiment développer la
marque public sénat au delà de la chaîne
strictement de la développer à travers
des contenus et d'utiliser aujourd'hui
tous les modes de diffusion que nous
avons des coûts sur les contenus les
réseaux sociaux bien sûr facebook
twitter mais également dans certains cas
sur l'appel des accords avec des
plateformes de diffusion comme la
plateforme salto comme je propose aussi
dans mon rapport de faire des podcasts
chaîne ne fait pas et qui est
véritablement un développement très fort
aujourd'hui de nouveaux contenus très
simple pas cher à faire on fait des
podcasts à dire du ch ont enregistré
ensuite on le diffuse sur des
plateformes par exemple france radio
france est une plateforme très
performante en matière de podcasts donc
je pense vraiment d'où l'idée aussi de
cette plateforme publique locale je
pense que il faut vraiment aller plus
loin mettre plus de moyens humains et
financiers
c'est ce que je disais dans le fait on
sait que les moyens sont constants donc
il faut faire des choix mais je crois
qu'il faut développer la diffusion de la
marque et de toutes ses formes de
programmes adaptés sur différentes
plateformes saas et le premier enjeu le
deuxième enjeu je les dis aussi c'est
que je crois qu'aujourd'hui il faut pas
sous-estimer la le canal lui même qui
est quand même le canal le plus vu de
l'ensemble des médias qu'à cette chaîne
et je pense que sur le canal
il ya un travail c'est quand on a deux
émissions quotidiennes la matinale et
puis l'émission du soir allons plus loin
qu'ils sont beaucoup rediffuser je pense
qu'il faut vraiment un travail très fin
je ne sais peut-être pas le lieu ici
mais je pourrais rentrer dedans là aussi
à la fois sur la forme et sur le fond
pour essayer que ces émissions apporte
vraiment tout ce qu'elles peuvent tout
ce qu'elles peuvent apporter et je pense
que le façon globale il ya une petite
question de modernité qui se pose parce
que encore une fois dans le monde de la
télévision on est dans un monde de
zapping
les gens ne vont pas toujours justes sur
votre chaîne cela arrive mais souvent il
passe d'une chaîne à l'autre et donc il
ya des choix des codes couleurs parfois
qui sont pas nécessairement les plus
attractifs le deuxième point je sais que
peut-être deux le deuxième point ce sont
les missions un prince est alors
l'émission intrinsèque je l'aï dit pour
moi c'est une chaîne parlementaire une
chaîne parlementaire c'est d'abord une
chaîne parlementaire c'est à dire c'est
d'abord une chaîne qui rencontrent des
travaux du sénat est en permanence dans
cette maison il ya en ce moment en
donnant un exemple en ce moment il ya je
crois deux missions qui travaille sur
les questions de la jeunesse des
étudiants d'une part des étudiants et
d'autre part des jeunes en général
étudiants ou pas étudiant avec tes
prennent d'inégalités voilà un sujet
majeur pour notre pays voilà un sujet
que la bande d'amis a encore accéléré je
pense que aussi bien sur le site que sur
la chaîne elle même avec des travaux
aussi riche qui s'étale durant des
semaines et des mois
je pense qu'il ya vraiment une matière
très importante et je les dis c'est
cette dimension de chaînes
parlementaires chaîne des cd des
sénateurs chaîne des travaux du sénat
alors ça n'empêche pas aussi le côté
chaîne civique c'est important chaîne
d'actualité je ferai peut-être le lien
avec la troisième question
bien sûr cette chaîne traite de
l'actualité sauf qu'aujourd'hui les
chaînes d'actualité
vous en avez un nombre mais sûrement de
pays qui doivent voir leur corps et
toutes accessibles en gratuit en tnt on
en a au moins 4 en 1 à 5,6 donc à
l'arrivée c'est un domaine extrêmement
concurrentiel et on le voit bien elle se
fond de concurrence beaucoup dans la
chute dans la surenchère
donc je pense de ce point de vue là que
public sénat a vraiment une carte
différente à jouer elle ne doit pas trop
singer essayer de faire une course à
l'échalote avec les chaînes d'info je ne
crois pas ça mais elle traite de
l'actualité
donc je pense qu'elle veut faire
entendre sa différence peut-être par
plus de profondeur dans ses analyses
et là encore une fois elle peut
s'appuyer sur les travaux du sénat
je pense de façon générale que
elle peut véritablement c'est d'ailleurs
une des raisons pour lesquelles je
présente pour ce projet c'est ce qui
m'intéresse dans cette chaîne je pense
qu'elle peut vraiment dans cet univers
je pense qu'elle peut vraiment avoir un
rôle un ton un style différent et le
dernier point si vous permettez
différence avec lcp
je dirais très simplement le sénat et
l'assemblée sont deux assemblées
représentatives mais elles ont un style
différent et je pense que ceux ci l'ont
doit on doit le voir sur chacune des
chaînes monsieur bell je donne la parole
à monsieur pierre laurin
merci madame la présidente bonjour
monsieur baldelli
j'avais prévu de vous interroger sur
l'évolution que vous envisagez des
modalités de diffusion vous avez déjà
pas de reprise aborder ce sujet et à
l'instant juste pourrait insister et
clarifier les choses sur l'avenir de la
de la tnt du canal 13 puisque vous vous
avez dit à l'instant que vous pensiez
qu'il n'était pas éternel donc qu'est ce
que ça veut dire dans votre esprit sur
les modes alternatifs de diffusion vous
avez donné vous avez donné plusieurs
exemples
est-ce que vous pouvez développer en
point là dessus notamment sur les
réseaux sociaux et avec quels objectifs
de diversification de renforcement du
public
vous envisagez cette diversification des
utilisations des modes de diffusion
alors d'abord sur le premier point
monsieur président très important
l'avenir la tnt je voudrais plutôt être
rassurant d'abord je suis absolument
c'est jose dire pro tnt parce que
d'abord c'est gratuit c'est non
identifiables c'est à dire la différence
de quand vous êtes abonné un opérateur
télécom qui vous fournit la télévision
quand vous regardez la tnt c'est de les
retient personne ne sait ce que vous
regardez quand vous le regardez et par
ailleurs c'est gratuit donc je pense que
la france a beaucoup développé la tnt à
la différence souvent d'autres pays
européens d'où la difficulté par rapport
au fait que la tnt potentiellement un
jour menacé mais en tout cas je
considère que c'est un atout très fort
pour la france très fort pour cette
chaîne est donc en tout état de cause il
faut si j'ose dire se battre pour qu'on
ait la tnt le plus longtemps
une fois qu'on a dit ça la difficulté
c'est que ce sont évidemment des
fréquences que d'autres acteurs
opérateurs
souvent je suis pas expert là mais
souvent télécoms vise à un moment donné
et c'est au niveau de la commission
européenne où il cherche toujours à
organiser un moment on l'a vu dans le
passé sur d'autres fréquences une
extinction dans chaque pays pour pouvoir
récupérer ces fréquences dont je le
disais il y à ma connaissance un rendez
vous prévu en 2025
mais normalement pas d'extinction avant
2030 au plus tôt donc ça veut dire que
ça normalement ça nous donne encore
largement de la marge
donc ça c'est le premier point le
deuxième point c'est le des modes
alternatifs de diffusion ils sont de
deux ordres
d'abord un peu se rassurer le jour où la
tnt s'arrêtera les chaînes linéaires
continueront à être diffusé pour le
compte par les acteurs télécoms qui
fournissent dans le même abonnement de
la télévision du téléphone et de
l'internet
c'est déjà aujourd'hui à peu près 70 %
de la consommation des français passent
par ce mode de diffusion l'a donc le
jour où la tnt s'arrête si elle s'arrête
un jour
pour autant public sénat aura toujours
un canal de diffusion comme elle l'a
déjà aujourd'hui chez ces opérateurs
mais la force de du bouquet tnt c'est
que ces opérateurs de par la loi sont
obligés de le reprendre telle qu'elle
est dans le même ordre et dans la même
numérotation ça c'est extrêmement
précieux c'est un atout formidable pour
cette chaîne sur vos deux autres
questions donc les modes de diffusion
alternatif the lady naturellement en
linéaire les opérateurs télécoms
mais en non linéaire évidemment twitter
facebook les nouveaux réseaux sociaux
qui arrive si on met des contenus s'il
est public sénat qui correspondent à
public sénat
on peut cela déjà fait aujourd'hui
naturellement mais on peut plus
largement utilisé ces contenus diffusion
qui ont quand même et ça renvoie à votre
troisième partie de votre question sur
la diversification du public évidemment
on est là sur des publics souvent plus
jeunes encore que il faut pas croire
qu'en font chaud de la journée utilise
pas aujourd'hui ça se développe
largement mais si culturellement on est
sur des publics plus jeunes donc ça
permet aussi par rapport à la tnt en
étant présent en numérique en ayant une
empreinte plus forte en numérique sur
ces réseaux d'aller aussi chercher des
publics plus jeunes
merci nous passons à la question de
monsieur loïc hervé monsieur mail daily
dans un contexte budgétaire contraint
comment comptez vous mettra en valeur à
l'antenne de public sénat
tous les territoires vous avez évoqué
cette question dans votre propos
liminaire avec la question toute
particulière des outre mer en prenant en
compte la couverture sur le terrain de
l'activité des sénatrices et des
sénateurs dans l'exercice de leur mandat
même si le mot a été prononcé plus on va
pas vous comment bien assurer l'égalité
entre les femmes et les hommes à
l'antenne alors sur le premier point
oui au total si vous voulez garder du
temps pour la conclusion il nous reste
trois questions encore d'accord merci
alors sur le sur le premier point sur
les territoires naturellement vous avez
raison envoyer des équipes des
journalistes en territoire a priori cinq
couches supplémentaires parce qu'elle le
temps du transport et du voyage il ya
plusieurs façons malgré tout de traiter
ça d'abord on a des partenariats avec
des titres de pqr ou des télévisions
locales donc on peut aussi se mettre
d'accord dans certains cas sur des
reportages partager et puis je crois
qu'il faut le faire je crois qu'il faut
l'assumer dans le dans le budget de la
chaîne alors ça veut pas dire je vais
bien l'outre-mer si on prend l'exemple
de l'outre-mer aujourd'hui il y un
magazine positive outre mer je crois
d'ailleurs qu'il n'est pas fait par les
journalistes de la chaîne mais qu'il est
sous traitée à une agence de production
il est assez courant en format il est
sur un bon principe qui est montrant les
choses positives sur l'outre-mer ya
joaillier 1 à la réunion un sujet sur
des vélos électriques assez intéressant
mais une fois qu'on a dit ça je crois
qu'il faut aussi accepter pour
l'outre-mer dans certains cas de voir
les difficultés
prenons un exemple la question du
logement outre-mer je crois que la
délégation la question de la
représentation sur les télévisions de
l'outre-mer là aussi la délégation de
l'outre-mer c'est des sujets dont elle
s'est emparée cd sujet sur lequel
travaille je pense qu'on peut aussi
parler de l'outre-mer à paris avec la
délégation
sur la question égalité homme femme
peut-être alors je suis à question
égalité hommes-femmes objectivement
quand je regarde l'antenne et des
principales émissions
il y en a un certain nombre qui sont
présentés par des par des femmes mais ce
que j'observe c'est que naturellement
dans ses émissions interviennent et
c'est normal beaucoup de gens je parle
pas des invités mais je parle d'experts
je parle de journalistes qui sont sur
des médias de pqr partenaires et là j'ai
pas le décompte mais en regardant cette
chaîne je ne suis pas sûr que dans ce
cadre là on soigne un parité je pense
qu'on est quand même assez masculin
alors sûrement que des efforts sont
faits mais je pense qu'on peut aller
plus loin 6 la parole est à madame
nathalie delattre
merci madame la présidente monsieur
baldelli j'ai lu avec grand intérêt
votre projet votre curriculum vitae deux
questions me sont venues spontanément la
première
quelle est votre activité depuis votre
départ de m6 en 2019 et la deuxième vous
êtes passé par rtl une grosse entreprise
vous avez souhaité diriger france
télévisions plus de dix mille personnes
et là vous souhaitez arrivait à public
sénat qui somme toute une petite pme à
côté pourquoi ce choix
merci alors madame la présidente pour
répondre à votre première question mais
vous y trouverez un peu la réponse à la
deuxième mais je répondrais expressément
la deuxième j'ai fait le choix après
avoir quitté effectivement le groupe m6
et la direction de rtl j'ai fait le
choix de me présenter à france
télévisions
je me suis retrouvé en situation
finalement de ne pas être choisi à la
fin du mois de juillet dernier et est
depuis je suis à la recherche d'un
emploi mais je j'ai toujours fonctionné
en coup de coeur par an qui est jean
vient la deuxième question la question
de la taille est pas une question qui
pour moi importe beaucoup
pourquoi dans ma vie professionnelle
j'ai commencé dans cette maison comme
administrateur au sénat j'ai en
permanence fait des périodes dans le
secteur public et des périodes dans le
privé là je sors de 15 ans dans le privé
j'étais très heureux j'ai fait beaucoup
de choses c'était vraiment très
intéressant de travailler toutes ces
équipes mais quand j'ai quitté ce groupe
là pourquoi j'ai décidé de me présenter
à france télévision parce que j'avais
vraiment le sentiment pour faire simple
que l'évolution du secteur privé en
télévision et une évolution qui va
peut-être est certainement vers moins de
sens et je pense que plus que jamais
dans notre société telle qu'elle évolue
le sens on en a besoin en tout cas moi
dans ma vie professionnelle je suis un
moment où je ne suis plus dans des
logiques carriériste ou de carrière ce
qui m'intéresse c'est si je veux donner
du sens c'est ce que je fais et ça a été
le sens de ma candidature à france
télévision parce que je connais bien le
secteur public pour avoir passé
notamment près de sept ans dans groupe
français evian a dirigé france bleu et
donc j'avais quelques idées sur ce que
l'on pouvait faire sans doute mieux sur
le secteur public
aujourd'hui vous avez raison public
sénat est une chaîne plus petit mais si
je regarde le budget des programmes ce
n'est pas rien j'ai dirigé dans groupe
m6 plusieurs chaînes paris première et
teva qui avait cet ordre de but de
budget de programme et je sais qu'on
peut faire beaucoup de choses avec ces
moyens là qui ne sont pas qui ne sont
pas négligeables et je pense vraiment
que ce qui compte le plus c'est l'envi
et c'est le sens quand on peut donner du
sens à son travail
c'est une chance formidable beaucoup de
gens qui aspirent beaucoup de gens n'y
arrive pas toujours mon j'ai peut-être
un peu la chance aujourd'hui de pouvoir
me le permettre en tout cas c'est une
préoccupation importante pour moi et je
considère que les médias en général et
particulièrement les médias publics ont
véritablement un rôle très important à
jouer dans le fonctionnement d'une
démocratie
merci je donne la parole à madame
jacqueline eustache brinio merci mme la
présidente
je veux revenir quelques instants aux
yeux sur notre projet stratégique
ce projet stratégique à sa lecture
comporte peu de propositions concrètes
concernant la couverture des travaux
parlementaires et celles de l'activité
des sénateurs dans l'exercice de leur
mandat et dans leur territoire
alors il ya des constats généraux que
nous partageons bien évidemment est-ce
que pourriez nous vous pourriez nous
précisez vos propositions éditoriales
pour public sénat en set nadal en la
matière s'il vous plaît je n'ai pas eu
accès et je ne sais pas si elles
existent aux audiences des émissions
donc je n'ai pas voulu c'est toujours
très difficile on va pas changer une
émission si elle fonctionne bien et si
les gens la trouve intéressante donc
pour vraiment avant de savoir ce qu'on
peut faire de différent et c'est la
raison pour laquelle j'aurais très bien
pu faire une grille de programme et vous
dire comme j'ai dirigé rtl géant
quelques années changer 100% des
programmes et moi j'adore faire ça
et à côté du côté dirigeants j'y
reviendrai je suis aussi un homme de
programme mais je pense qu'aujourd'hui
avant de dire on va changer ceci et cela
il faut un peu respectée des programmes
existants les gens qu'ils les font donc
il faut se faire une analyse plus
précise ce faire une analyse plus
précise il faut quand même avoir
l'audience de ses programmes
je ne sais pas aujourd'hui où en est
cette chaîne en termes
l'audience qui fait froid en france
c'est médiamétrie je ne sais pas
aujourd'hui quelle est l'audience de ses
programmes
maintenant j'ai fait des propositions
néanmoins sur les programmes et j'y
reviendrai et on peut en faire d'autres
j'ai fait la proposition d'un programme
qui s'appellerait le sénat et vous parce
que je pense comme je le disais que en
permanence dans cette maison il y à
travers des propositions de loi à
travers des missions d'information à
travers parfois des questions écrites ou
orales des sujets très concrets qui
concerne les français qui peuvent les
intéresser je pense que c'est important
d'avoir un module qui permet de le voir
je vous donne un exemple je crois que
c'est une initiative sénatoriales il ya
une proposition de loi qui a été fait
pour que les véhicules de collection
puisse continuer à circuler dans les
zones urbaines qui sont des zones
préservées en terme en termes
d'environnement
et bien cette proposition de là je crois
qu'elle est elle vit sa vie
je sais pas si elle sera définitivement
adoptée mais en tout cas voilà
typiquement quelque chose ça concerne
peut-être une population limitée mais
plein de petites briques montre que à
l'arrivée le sénat concerne
potentiellement dans ses actions dans
ses décisions
tous les français ça c'est un exemple
l'autre exemple je les dis je pourrais
rentrer dans le détail mais ce n'est
peut-être pas le lieu
je pense que l'émission
qui fait la matinale de public sénat
ainsi que l'émission disons plus de
débats allons plus loin du soir je pense
qu'il ya un travail non négligeable à
faire sur ces émissions
merci monsieur baldé l'idée pour la suze
et moi si madame la présidente je vais
plus avoir de conclusion mais et je
pense aussi mais ça ça mérite peut-être
d'en discuter davantage avec les
sénatrices et des sénateurs je pense
qu'une émission sur les mers qui est
pour part des clients quelque chose que
vous connaissez très bien parce que
souvent vous l'avez été où c'est vos
interlocuteurs
je pense qu'une émission sur les mers
serait aussi très intéressante parce que
là on aurait une diversité formidable
pour le groupe en terme de territoire en
termes de taille de ville etc
et en terme d'activité et ne peut parler
de tout en parlant d'une pile et en
parlant avec son maire peut parler de
sanitaires mais un jour on peut aussi
parler d'autre chose
et pour conclure les questions quelques
années la merci madame la présidente
monsieur votre projet présente des
propositions assez précises dont
documents écrits en ce qui concerne le
contrôle de gestion et le suivi de la
dépense notamment la proposition vous
avez d'ailleurs abordé je crois tout à
l'heure d'un budget on base 0 pouvez
vous préciser votre démarche notamment
les conséquences éventuelles en matière
de ressources humaines et ensuite
quelles marges identifiez vous d'ores et
déjà pour améliorer éventuellement la
gestion alors le budget base zéro je le
redis peut-être en un mot ça consiste à
se dire aujourd'hui un budget il ya une
chaîne qui fonctionne c'est ce qui s'est
accumulée en 20 ans avec plein de
décision si aujourd'hui on devait faire
cette chaîne ex nihilo on réexamine
toutes les dépenses est ce qu'on ferait
la même chose
est ce qu'on ferait différemment en tout
cas ça permet d'avoir des analyses ça
permet de voir démarche après on décide
de les utiliser ou de ne pas les
utiliser
donc soyons clairs là dessus par rapport
à la deuxième partie de votre question
je les dis aujourd'hui je ne connais pas
le budget de cette chaîne j'en connais
le montant global je n'en connais pas le
détail donc je ne peux pas aujourd'hui
je le ferais assez facilement quand
j'examinerai ce budget si je suis amené
à l'examiner je les fait souffrir dans
ma vie professionnelle mais aujourd'hui
je ne peux pas vous dire sur tout
et quelles sont les marges puisque je
n'y ai pas eu accès mais en revanche je
les dis dans un budget il n'y a pas
qu'un budget il ya des personnes qui
travaillent à des personnels c'est bien
sûr un coût mais c'est ce qui fait que
la chaîne existe et sur ce sujet là je
les ai toujours fait dans les
entreprises que j'ai dirigé publics
comme privés je suis garant du dialogue
social c'est à dire je pense savoir
discuter avec les personnels pour
trouver les bonnes solutions et pas des
solutions qui ne leur conviennent pas
j'ai oublié il y avait je crois un
dernier point dans votre question
monsieur le questeur professionnalisant
savoir si vous aviez déjà identifié des
démarches je crois que vous avez répondu
mais ce bel délit il vous reste donc à
conclure dans la limite des 40 minutes
qui vous sont impartis et donc va
écouter sans plus attendre
vous vous laissant la parole et nous
vous écoutons alors j'ai combien de
temps exactement
ce termine à 40 minutes j'aurai cette
minute valeurs je pense que je vaux
libérerait plutôt jeu comme j'ai eu
l'occasion de vous dire j'ai commencé ma
vie professionnelle dans cette maison
puisque j'étais administrateur d'abord
la commission des affaires économiques
puis à la commission des finances c'est
d'ailleurs dans cette maison quelque
part que j'ai découvert le l'intérêt qui
ne m'a plus quitté ensuite du secteur
audiovisuel puisque j'ai eu le privilège
de travailler avec le sénateur jean
cluzel qui était le rapporteur et lina
mans reconnu de ce secteur c'est lui qui
m'a tout appris
c'est lui qui m'a permis de comprendre
ces entreprises de rencontre les enjeux
de six entreprises et de rencontrer les
gens qui les dirigeait j'ai vraiment ce
que j'ai appris au scénar j'ai appris de
l'exigence du travail
j'ai appris l'intérêt du bicamérisme et
derrière l'intérêt du bicamérisme en
réalité c'est la capacité canton
administrateurs vote au sénat
on travaille avec des sénateurs de tous
les bords politiques et donc on est là
pour travailler avec eux et quelque part
les aider dans ce qu'ils veulent dire
dans un rapport dans un projet de loi
est donc pour moi les questions de de
pluralisme les questions de
compréhension des autres les questions
de tenir compte de toutes les opinions
sont des sujets essentiels je les ai
vraiment dans ma vie personnelle et dans
ma vie professionnelle
j'aime travailler ensemble j'aime
débattre j'aime écouter les opinions des
autres et le cas échéant surtout quand
elles ne sont pas les mêmes que les
vôtres
parce que c'est ça qui permet d'évoluer
ou d'en changer
et ça je crois que
grâce au sénat je les fait durant les
plus de vingt ans où j'ai dirigé des
entreprises en télé en radio en
numérique ce véritablement sa constituer
une partie de ma façon de voir j'ai
toujours veillé dans ses médias à
respecter tous les équipes d'opinion
j'ai toujours considéré que ces médias
il faut dire cette idée des grands
médias nationaux et vocation à
s'adresser à tout le monde sans
exclusive et je crois profondément au
respect du pluralisme et d'ailleurs
quand on prend la chaîne public sénat
elle a une particularité c'est qu'elle
n'est pas de contrôler sur son
pluralisme parle c'est ça la différence
de tous les autres médias mais en
revanche elle a une exigence plus forte
qui est une exigence légale qui figure
dans la loi modifiée de 1986 puisque
c'est l'exigence de l'impartialité c'est
une exigence très forte plus forte
aujourd'hui en france ni les chaînes
publiques ni les chaînes privées non une
exigence aussi forte
il faut aller à l'étranger c'est la bbc
qui dans sa charte à une exigence
d'impartialité
donc je crois que ça ce sont des choses
qui sont pour moi essentiel dans tout
médias parce que c'est comme ça que des
médias réussissent à être respecté et à
être crédible auprès de nos concitoyens
le deuxième point je les dis vous le
savez je suis un manager excusez-moi de
l'anglicisme je suis un gestionnaire
mais j'aime profondément travailler au
contact de mes équipes c'est là que j'ai
toujours éprouvé le plus de plaisir de
satisfaction je suis pas de ce point de
vue là un manager hors sol distance je
suis un manager impliqués ce qui
m'intéresse c'est le travail de tous les
jours avec les équipes c'est monteiro ce
sont mes équipes c'est là que le travail
est agréable et c'est même quand on a
des difficultés
évidemment quand on à faire face mais
c'est ça qui nous c'est ça qui nous
enrichit je suis aussi un président qui
a toujours su faire évoluer les
entreprises qui doit diriger publics
comme privés notamment sur les questions
de numérique
si je prends l'exemple de france
télévisions au début des années 2000
j'ai mis en place et dirigé
la filiale france télévisions
interactive si je prends rtl j'ai
beaucoup développée sur rtl l'info
numérique de telle sorte que airtel est
rentré dans le top 10 de l'info
numérique en france
si je regarde le groupe m6 c'est moi qui
ai conçu avec mes équipes et lancer la
première offre deux podcasts de ce
groupe mais je suis aussi un homme de
programme et un homme de contenus c'est
au fond ce qui m'intéresse le plus dans
un média parce que c'est dans ce qu'on
donne à voir dans ce qu'on montre c'est
là que se crée le lien avec nos
concitoyens et c'est là qu'on peut
donner du sens c'est là qu'on peut leur
apporter quelque chose
et quand je dirigeais rtl je n'étais pas
seulement président de rtl
j'ai aussi très largement changer les
programmes la grille et parce qu'en
réalité
parallèlement j'étais également moi même
le directeur des programmes landes
groupe m6 j'étais pas seulement
vice-président du groupe
mais j'étais également le dirigeant en
charge de l'ensemble de l'information du
groupe que ce soit en radio en
télévision ou en numérique
pour finir je dirais que public sénat a
une utilité certaine et une singularité
c'est pour ça que cela mérite que l'on
s'y intéresse
c'est pour ça si je puis me permettre
que je m'intéresse à public sénat parce
que j'ai envie de mettre toute mon envie
mais aussi mon expérience au service de
ce projet que je vous ai présenté
je pense que cette chaîne a besoin d'une
visibilité une modernité qu'elle mérite
et qu'il faut sans toujours dans cet
univers média qui va très vite qu'il
faut sans cesse réussir à mettre en
avant à montrer et à démontrer je crois
que le sénat a un rôle essentiel à jouer
dans nos institutions dans les valeurs
républicaines et vous me permettrait de
finir devant vous en citant victor hugo
victor hugo avait dit aux sénateurs
montrez que vous êtes nécessaire ça
remonte à bien longtemps ils ont
largement montré depuis eh bien moi je
souhaite que public sénat montre
également plus que jamais qu'elle est
nécessaire
merci
eh bien écoutez merci monsieur bell
delhi pour votre conclusion est votre
audition est maintenant terminée nous
vous remercions et nous avons maintenant
terminée l'ensemble des auditions
publiques des candidats sélectionnés
pour la présidence direction générale de
public sénat et notre commission de
sélection à présent va délibérer à huit
clos afin de proposer un ou plusieurs
candidats au président du sénat en vue
de la réunion de bureau qui est prévue
le 15 avril prochain et qui désignera le
futur pdg de la chaîne
je vous remercie
[Musique]